hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and ah
just checking in on you
just checking in to see how your week's
going how are you oh Billy back brace
Oh Billy back brace is [__] laying
here with his legs elevated dude
underrated throwing out your back
you get to lay around and cancel [__] oh
dude dude
dude I'd love to but I threw out my back
oh you don't say
what happened
oh you know the freezer you know the the
goddamn freezers at the bottom of the
refrigerator and wouldn't you know I
went down to get a frozen waffle in the
suction from the freezer just caused
this that little bit of resistance in a
full oh yeah the forward bends are the
worst dude and you're out
and you're up you don't have to do
[__] [__] I don't have to even
emotionally support my wife right now
that's how I feel you know
I don't have to do [__] so that's what
I'm doing I've been watching some movies
yesterday I fired up the [__] Aviator
um I got like through the first uh 45
minutes of that every every movie that
you guys are recommending by the way for
whatever reason is two hours and 50
minutes long
Casino Jackie Brown heat in The Aviator
are all like three hour [__] movies
do you know what I got time to watch
them because I ah dude I threw out my
back
that's right up there with uh I got kids
I got to go home the kids you know I got
to get back to the kids I got to let's
let's top five
I gotta get the [__] out of here I don't
want to talk to you you know
you know when you just get cornered with
somebody who just like won't shut the
[__] up Nia you know what that's like
right every day you know every day it's
so difficult living with old Billy back
brace
um
when um
you know somebody won't shut the [__] up
and you're not giving them anything and
and that you the person will literally
talk to the side of your face
for 40 straight [__] minutes they
just won't get it they just don't get
the [__] hint that you as a human
being have disengaged from Whatever
Whatever life experience
that has created them to do what they're
doing to you right then right
if that isn't working if they can
literally sit there and talk to the side
of your [__] face like you're a horse
and they're brushing your back
at that point
you have to go with you got to go with
an excuse all right now you can't go
with I I threw out my back that only
works over the phone and via text
you know if they face time just make
sure you're laying down you just have
that look on your face and you'll be
good right
in person
when someone's being the old horse
trainer talking to the side of your
[__] head right I would say you got
to go with I got kids I got a dog
uh I don't know where to go after that
Nia what's a good one to get out of a
[__] somebody's just talking inside
of your [__] head what's a good one
to get out of there I gotta get up early
in the morning I gotta get up but show
me I gotta get up early in the morning
dang good answer
I gotta get you know what my buddy of
mine used the other day I gotta take a
piss
Ed
it just
he didn't have to go wait just to get
out of a conversation to get out of it
because I was so annoying and he just
kept trying to get out of it he couldn't
so he went with me yeah yeah no I always
excuse myself to the ladies room but the
great thing is he didn't have to go so
then he just went in there and stood you
always have to go a little bit I guess
you can make it happen or you can act
like it or you can just stand there go
in to the bathroom and then when you
come out oh I ran into somebody else and
so I don't get back to the conversation
yeah or nia
you could just go with straight up
honesty
and just stop staring off into the
[__] tree line and turn your head to
him and just be like buddy
you're killing me
foreign
you're killing me like what
I mean I literally have not even made a
facial expression forget about sent any
words your way for at least 11 minutes
you know those are the people who don't
pick up on social cues sociopaths
no not sociopaths people who just don't
pick up on social cues where they can't
recognize the fact that you're not into
this conversation anymore and they just
keep talking at you not even to you but
just at you you know what's worse than
that is this someone that does pick up
on the social cues and they realize you
don't want to talk to them which causes
them
they they already have like low
self-esteem so then they think that they
can just like
they can fix it and they can just keep
going and make it happen like they're
going to turn you around
yeah and that's when you have to be like
you know what I need to just run to the
restroom
or you just get graphic I gotta take a
[__]
real bad ah
that's people oh yeah I'll go with you
that's what the person will say what
I'll go with you and then like you're in
the stall and there's like oh I gotta go
you know they're standing outside the
stall still talking to you
um anyway no you got to go with honesty
I'm getting good at that Nia
I'm getting [__] good at like uh you
know
in that you know it's weird as a
comedian you can do it would you say
yeah [__] you you know because it
doesn't mean anything it's it's stupid
everybody else is watching so no one
takes it well for the most part nobody
takes it seriously
um and then came social media
um
I'm getting better at that in my uh
in my everyday life
I actually used that this guy was just
[__] like
you know
watch I
I just watched these guys break down a
game which I there's nothing worse than
listening to [__] people breaking
down a game yeah why don't you break
down the game right and it doesn't it
doesn't even matter what they say
they're not held accountable it's just
like just talk about this sport for like
that oh my God I just picked up on the
social cue of your face you don't want
all right sorry
see that you see what I did
oh my God you know what you should have
done in the middle of that being like
hey I gotta go to the bathroom
I just realized I got to get out of here
you know I actually Nia I I noticed a
lot of your social cues and I got to be
honest with you they bug me
yeah I hate when I'm interrupting
whatever you're doing and then and then
you pretend like you don't hear me
interrupting you and you want to teach
me a social lesson that when two people
are talking you just don't come walking
up like a toddler and talking to them I
hate when you do that what am I supposed
to to do stop turn around and address
your husband
so have you learned anything
yeah you know what I've learned that
you're gonna take as much why why did I
ask that if did you learn anything never
give Bill Burr an opening to explain
himself further
you are that person that just talks and
talks and talks and doesn't realize when
the other person is zoned out that's my
whole podcast that's my whole podcast
explain how the auto rotation works in
your [__] helicopter for the 20th
time God knows we need to hear that
story again
yeah
all right guilty is charged
no I'm guilty as charged I realized the
one of the main things that attracted me
to you is also once again what always
happens it's this thing that [__]
annoys me the most about you right yes
exactly
what does that mean that means I
understand completely
I don't think I've ever I don't think I
need you now repels me all right
oh you're trashing me again
so what is it that attracted you to me
that now annoys annoys you you know what
I realized it would be really dumb for
me to answer that question so I'm not
going to okay I was kind of hoping that
it would bother you that I didn't answer
that and he'd be like well what is it no
I'm a I need to know what the mystery is
I know I'm good you don't care but you
got to figure out what [__] Susie
faked tits said to Betty Botox
every week on the [__] real
housewives the real households the
[__] Aberdeen [__] County
huh where are they going next Nia if
you're running that franchise yeah where
do you the next city where's the next
time that you can find [__] five
washed up [__]
that didn't that married for money
rather than [__] love
fake they haven't done Vegas yet
well I bet those tricks would be cool
out there
you know why Nia because they know the
score
hey baby nobody comes to Vegas looking
for love you come to Vegas you're
looking for something else
can I interest you in a high ball
whatever the [__] you drank back in the
day
um so what are you gonna do all day
today Nia
huh
I don't care
gonna get it again I'm gonna [__]
have lunch with my friends
and be like baby get the [__] out of the
bedroom
um
why am I going at you today
happen to be sitting here so now it's
like oh you're here let me just use you
yeah when I was in improv College they
taught me to use in part of college I
actually have one accredited credit on
an accredited course at improv College
wait what was your major in college are
you told me Communications right I had a
bunch of majors and then I settled on
Communications
yeah and by the time I came around they
changed that to media arts so I don't
think you can get a Communications
through it was media arts you're telling
me I'm so old what I majored in doesn't
even exist anymore I think so at our
school I don't think so I think they
changed it to media arts
which is just as general I majored in
being the town executioner
like they didn't know who that guy was
like when he came up with this [__]
shirt off you know what I mean but he
has got a hood with the hood on his face
does that even um
I mean how many executions could they go
to and you'd be like Mike I didn't see
it the execution again
I was there I was uh
Mike you're not
you're not the Executioner are you oh no
me come on you know I can't keep a
secret
[Laughter]
all right so where are you gonna be on
Thursday they're they're executing
somebody else I hope I'll be up I'll be
around you know what he was like that
guy on Saturday Night Fever I was
looking a few guys where were you you
were up on the platform [__]
thank you
cut jebediah's head off you knew him
when I put the hood on hood or somebody
else
it's Billy the Executioner Oh Billy the
Executioner
was that a wrestler
the Executioner was Bernard Hopkins I
believe that a wrestler no he's one of
the great boxers of all time oh because
he was the Tom Brady of boxing he went
into his 40s and was still kicking ass
on people who were in their 20s it seems
like the name of a wrestler like an 80s
the Executioner
no they had
um didn't they have the um the Grim
Reaper no am I making that up you're now
making me forget everybody's name
because you're almost getting them right
the Undertaker The Undertaker didn't
they have the Grim Reaper
didn't they have Portuguese power no it
was polish power Ivan put Steve with
death so that what is it the Undertaker
okay the Undertaker got it and he threw
mankind
a body slang choke slam them on top of
the cage and he fell the essentially two
stories and landed on his entire
backside from the the back of his feet
to the back of his head and I remember
the way his leg was like crossed over
his other leg I'm like that's how people
look when they're dead when they fall to
their death you know your shoes always
pop off too by the way on impact oh okay
yeah if you're ever hovering over your
body and looking at it and your shoes
aren't on take a note of your shoes yes
that means you're not going to hover
back into it and get to tell like Nikki
Sixx when he OD'd on heroin his shoes
were still on
and that's what he knew it was probably
boots he's a rock star
you know it was okay to float back into
his body
all right I gotta go to the bathroom uh
oh no
uh we'll be right back with boring your
spouse after these messages you know
what I don't have a lot to talk about
because I haven't done anything because
my back hurt oh yeah let me
know I will tell you I don't take that
[__] you keep giving it to me Nia it
doesn't [__] do anything except beat
the [__] out of my liver liver nothing
like you're taking it every day for the
last month
where the [__] does that mean I I don't
let me I don't want any
I don't want any
excuse me Nia
hey Nia no means no
don't mean want any means don't want any
no I don't want that stuff is not doing
anything this just has to work itself
out
as I watch two hour and 50 minute movies
Nia do you have a suggestion for a movie
that I could watch before I get back out
into the world
a suggestion for a movie oh God
all right
fantastic
I don't want any
why won't you take any pain relief for
your back because I'm not in pain you're
not in pain no I mean an
uncomfortableness
no because I just don't I don't think
the uh listening to you complain about
it every day so why don't you [__]
take something
I haven't been complaining about it
every day
um my bad
I am here you're going for the laugh I
never said oh my back
here I'm not taking that take it right
now
oh I almost had it come on
all right
[Laughter]
look at me one of those I feel like I'm
one of those psych ward movies
oh Jesus did you go to the bathroom and
get four happy pills wow what a [__]
oh Florence Nightingale
you have to find it Well I guess their
little back won't hurt anymore
I'll get the shop vac don't worry about
it sweetheart
when did you only start wearing jumpers
were you a [__] mechanic
is that a one piece no
no oh
anyway speaking of helicopters I did fly
the other day oh God and I'm telling you
you got to come up with me Nan it rained
out out here it looks like you're going
over Ireland
yeah and you sat and you're in in that
position in your helicopter for how long
listen you would have no problem if I
was wrong a little over an hour okay and
you came back and you're like ah I
probably shouldn't probably shouldn't
have rid of my helicopter and sat like
that for a couple hours oh oh my back
is that what I said yes
I don't think I said that I think I said
you should go up there man it looks like
Ireland I felt like it was in the Irish
Spring commercial
the hills are all green you got it seem
to Hills Have Eyes near the hills are
all green you got to go up now before it
all turns brown and lights on fire and
you watch people running for their lives
okay
you can do whale watching in March
go right down the coast of [__]
Malibu I would do well watching would
you do whale watching but once you go to
any local mall
you'll see him wearing Hawaiian shirts
[Laughter]
there's a fun way to throw out your back
hot fudge sundaes
foreign
there is something so amazing about a
supermarket with the level of [__] that
they that they will sell in there that
could [__] kill you and you have to
go in there and as an adult and just
avoid all of that [__] in you do you
know that in in you can go into a
supermarket and they have fudge that you
can heat up to be hot fudge they got ice
cream they got whipped cream they have
this whole section of different toppings
have you seen the madness you know when
you go down there and you're like
Mary or whatever the hell you say
sandwich and I go down there right
it's probably my voice that's my inner
fat guy boy
parents right and you stand there and if
there's like you know we should go see
the
with um
Brendan um what's his name Hughes no
um what's his name
oh my God taglia boo what
no no no no no no
Frasier yes thank you is it Brendan or
Brandon Brendan right Brendan Frazier
I've never been able to get either one
of those names right I know whenever
it's someone's name Brendan I call them
Brandon whenever they're Brandon I call
them yeah you might as well call your
kid tomato
[Laughter]
hey tomato it's tomato
sorry tomato it's to me
um
is he a gambler
or is he fat why do they call him the
whale
he's yes he's like severely obese
oh it's Darren Aronofsky who did the
wrestler
I love the wrestler I watched the rest
Black Swan I couldn't deal with man I
love Black Swan when she was doing
something with her nails or getting her
back was bleeding or something and I was
just like I don't want to watch this
that movie was it was incredible
I just love that watching a tortured
but he did uh Operation Dumbo Drop
he did yeah
he did Pee-wee's Big Adventure
now that's one that that's that's the
reboot that's the reboot what reboot you
do this the second Pee Wee movie which
was Pee-wee's Big Top or something you
do it with Operation Dumbo Drop you
[__] reboot that elephant you get him
with Paul Rubens
bam and you reboot that elephant yeah
Bette Midler sing the soundtrack you are
the elephant beneath my ass
fly fly high remember those menstruation
songs that would just go to number one
you are the wind beneath my wings
wasn't that about that one week a month
where you guys are
disagreeable
was that in a tampon commercial
it was
you guys could see the way she's looking
at me do you remember that movie you are
the wind beneath my wings
this is such an important movie for
women
you know each day
a woman dies while her friend sits there
singing a sappy song to her and finally
Hollywood Cinema
has devoted some time to it have you
ever even seen beaches
I just remember it was really like lit
like lit like [__]
like there's a lot of light on this
movie
I think they're trying to make everybody
Angelic what happened again that's what
you remember from the movie was the
lighting they were on like a beach and
the ladies like hey just to let you know
I got lupus and she goes what
she goes I got lupus and she goes no no
she's totally codependent
that movie it was so sad it's just about
lifelong friends and yes then one of
them passes away yeah why do I want to
go through that like like that's like
people will sit there and [__] on me for
making fun of that movie somebody
thought that somebody's losing their
best friend to [__] lupus was this is
a [__] this is entertainment
having a deep connection to someone and
you know they grew up together as little
girls and like a lifelong friendship
that's what the movie is about yeah
which is fun and it makes me feel good
and then all of a sudden one of them
gets an ingrown toenail that turns again
green they gotta cut her leg off like
why do I want to watch that
like there's not enough sadness I go
into the movies to be in a good mood but
I want I I [__] hate sad movies
okay you hate sad movies you hate scary
movies you hate suspenseful movies yeah
I don't need I have all of that in my
life this is these are the movies that
Bill relates to anything violent
funny and funny yeah violence and humor
that's a narrow window that's what you
like out of your movies I like it no
sadness
no scariness
yeah no best friend dying
okay
listen yeah I love how you're making me
beat the asthma you're the one that goes
you're just extremely simple
you're the one who goes to bed watching
other people's [__] the murder shows
I don't know why you [__] sit there
watching that [__] you know what I
figured out why women like it oh now
it's all women
okay
uh oh who are you to shy away from a
generalization of women get the [__] out
of here fair enough fair enough I
realize I think why women will watch
murder shows because I think it gives us
some sort of sense of control because
you're always feeling like someone's
either gonna like kidnap you or murder
you at any point anyway so you feel like
you watch these shows and you're like oh
yeah yeah I'm learning the the warning
signs the red flags and you all you can
sort of distance yourself from it and be
like well that would never happen to me
because but the truth is if you end up
getting into a situation where you get
killed which is usually by somebody
close to you
a man Close to You chances are like
there's not necessarily A Way
out I mean you know what's amazing about
that
obviously you just see them when you the
first lines of any kind of abuse but a
lot of times you're just manipulated and
you're in a situation where you can't
get out of anyway so that's like the
really scary part of it all right thank
you Nia thank you for coming on here
with that public service you know what
you watch those movies you watch those
shows you feel like you got have some
sort of control and understanding of it
please don't act like you're not talking
90 of this podcast you want to be on
this thing so I'm going to talk
but now I'm done okay you watch those
murder shows for the same reasons why I
watched the Steven Seagal movie
because as a man you always have to
think what if 30 Jamaicans come into
this bar
a bar called Mark for death and they all
try to kill me at the same time
is he still alive Steven Seagal yeah
Steven Seagal is he still alive he's
trying to defeat his last opponent which
is death oh
um
uh yeah I think he's still alive oh okay
you didn't get into the Steep come on
man Stephen or young Steven Seagal
ponytail any of those movies first of
all because you watch murder shows why
wouldn't you watch a guy walking around
[__] everybody up in a bar in the 80s
when I was like a kid why would I be
watching Steven Seagal movies well
[__] the wings beneath my wind was in
the 80s yeah I know but I was like I
didn't watch it until I was older and
that's not exactly like mine all right
so when you got older you didn't watch a
Steven Seagal had no interest
come on baby that [__] jet black hair
pulled back the ponytail yeah no The
Whisper voice
never drawn where's the gun because any
level no all right who was your favorite
Action Hero of the 80s
Schwarzenegger Sly Stallone
the muscles from Brussels
who was that oh Jean-Claude Van Damme
Jean Claude Van Damme no when he hit
those splits ooh baby they hit those
splits okay so the spleen like the
splits better than uh no I'd like to get
a little Choppa I used to watch Magnum
PI with my parents does that count
who flew the helicopter wait did he fly
the helicopter no Magnum drove the car
the black guy he he did the helicopter
TC I liked him I liked Apollo Creed more
than I liked Rocky so it was very sad
when he passed away
okay
did you notice when you watched Magnum
PI that Higgins
how much the old Higgins the butler no
he was sort of the [__] old guy
he was the butler I was like hello
Magnum did you notice how much he looked
like Hitler it was [__] unbelievable
now that you say it he looked exactly
like Hitler he dressed like Hitler
and it was just like they never really
mentioned where they did with Hitler's
body it's like did this guy flying from
Argentina I used to watch this this
audition Knight Rider
I like that show a lot oh Knight Rider
was [__] great the talking I rock
yeah I'm gonna watch those TV shows then
she watched the Fall Guy no
what do you have against a white man in
a Chevy Silverado
[Laughter]
oh that used to what what about
um what about Matt Houston
I don't know what that is dude that was
the [__] the height of everybody like
Burt Reynolds set the standard of what a
good-looking guy was and that opened the
door for the guy who played Matt Houston
[__] Tom Selleck it was uh uh uh uh
uh who's the guy the guy eating the
sandwich on the floor there who drove
the [__] Trans Am David Hasselhoff
do you know I did a table read one time
and I was sitting right next to him and
I'm going to tell you right now the mo
the best looking guy I've ever seen in
my life really I was like looking at the
guy going like this like [__] like
you drew him
full head of hair the curly wavy hair
the chicks like the [__] dimple in
the chin you know what I remember for
Magnum tall as [__] is when he's in the
opening credits of the opening sequence
when the girl is like snorkeling or
something and he's helping her quote
unquote her only looks up and he's like
oh I mean just another day in the life
of Magnum PI that's right what is he
doing exactly was he teaching her how to
swim why did he need why does she need
to be held up like that well listen do
you think Magnum do you think Magnum
what was he doing first of all it was
raining okay it was raining it was
raining P for old Magnum oh that's why
you had the t-tops open he didn't want
to crack them when those [__] jumped
in his [__] Fiat or whatever he drove
the Ferrari Corvette no it was a Ferrari
it's funny that's like one of the the
worst Ferraris that they made evidently
who's I love you baby who loves you baby
lollipop no come on I watched that with
my stepdad he he used to watch that show
that's Kojak tell us hello Jack he would
watch the reruns of that
so I watched that guy I watched it I
watched that
The Equalizer never saw that did you
used to I would watch Mash with them
[Music]
I stopped it with that stop doing
what
suicide is painless isn't that the song
[Music]
no they're in Korea oh Korea that was
the the thing when it was like um
the the show lasted longer than the
actual conflict
it's called the Korean conflict it was
never called a war okay
all right well I wasn't like I wasn't
yelling that at you I was just giving
you that information yeah and I'm
accepting that all right speaking of
that I have other information I have
information that is actually
unlike of Interest unlike myself is
actually exciting
um
all right
the Patrice O'Neill comedy benefit is
back ladies and gentlemen tickets for
the 10th Annual 10th Annual Nia Patrice
O'Neill comedy benefit go on sale today
Thursday January 19th at 12 p.m Eastern
Standard Time the show is on Tuesday
April 4th
2023 uh it's 7 30 P.M
at the New York City Center the lineup
includes Mo uh amber Bill Burr Shane
Gillis this is all in alphabetical order
Bobby Robert Kelly
Eleanor Kerrigan Jim Norton Keith
Robinson Cipher sounds Ricky Velez and
Rick Voss Rich Voss oh my God I said
Rick Rich Voss and maybe some surprise
guests will drop by to buy tickets to go
to any of the following uh
www.new York Center citycenter.org
patrice10 uh the Theater box office is
located at 131 West 55th Street between
6th and 7th Avenue box office hours are
Monday through Saturday 12 P.M
uh to 8 p.m and Sunday 12 noon to 7 30
p.m there you go
um it's the 10th one that we've done but
it's been over 10 years he died in uh
November
of uh 2011. so it's actually been 11
years would you believe me yep
a lot has changed
um
all right everybody look who it is it's
neutral full look who it is look who it
is oh look who there he is there he is
there he is there he is
I got to give a shout out to the podcast
look what crappens right watch watch
what happens now they talk about no just
watch what crappens all right starring
Ronnie Karam and Ben mandelker yeah
[__] hilarious I saw the podcast live
it was amazing and as funny as they were
their [__] crowd was even funnier
those women were ready wasted they were
[__] ready wasted and ready for them
to talk about the real house so their
bid is so fun their bid is the Jersey
guys they always they announce people
and things like somebody comes walking
around there he is
they order food they order food and the
waitress brings it over there it is
there it is
there she is
they are going on tour as well who are
watch your croppins they're going back
on tour oh I was hoping the Jersey
people going on tour I've been listening
to what they had to say all right
neutral full there it is
Jersey Housewives is coming back will
you be watching it with me like you did
last season
um I will be but my favorite one come on
I feel like now that the guy's deported
she's already done her jail time I mean
where do you go from there a drama
because because her and this is like on
Roseanne when all of a sudden they won
the lottery they were on her brother
you're my [__] father yeah exactly
there's a lot of that so it's gonna be
dramatic
yeah all right you know I just like that
the sociopath one there's one the one
who she looks like uh a villa
velociraptor
the one who's just like I don't know
what I was signing I mean I just ain't
put it in front of me yeah
yeah
she looks like a velociraptor
no no she
does you know what she looks
just like that lizard and that
that guy was tripping and they they
automated it
automated animated it and he was going
like uh
uh what was the name of that [__]
YouTube video
it was his classic thing this guy they
some people say it's true some say it's
not it was a guy and he was [__]
tripping balls on LSD mushrooms and he
was just talking about what he was
what he was saying and he was just going
look at that kid over there going crazy
he was doing all of this [__] and for
whatever reason they they took the audio
and they just had like um this lizard
just saying it and the lizard that they
drew looks like that woman that [__]
those people out of that money and acted
like she didn't know what she was doing
sorry
um I think you're getting your
Housewives confused but that's okay I'm
not
but her husband got deported in the I
don't know am I going to argue about
this you're right you're right I got the
wrong thing no no I know what you're
talking about neutral fall confusing it
with somebody else okay you don't have
to choose between oh this is for me you
know you don't have to choose between
better hair growth and your health uh
there's a holistic solution for men that
promotes both healthier hair and whole
body Wellness
or healthier hair it's not saying it
grows it back right get ahead of
thinning hair oh it prevents it well
it's too late for me with neutrophils
whole body approach to hair growth you
can be George The Animal steel no drugs
no compromises neutrophone is the number
one dermatologist recommended hair
growth supplement
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth thickness invisible scalp
coverage there you go neutral Falls hair
growth
what Nutri neutral Falls hair growth I
can't read that word what is what does
that say genetics
no
no the word above it the word
nutraceuticals like Pharmaceuticals but
neutral oh he said genetics
all right neutral
neutral Falls hair growth
nutraceuticals nutrienticals go beyond
genetics
[Laughter]
to multi-target the root causes of
thinning including stress hormones
nutrition
metabolism metabolism oh metabolism
[Laughter]
what did I say
metabolism I don't even know metabolism
meta World Peace
ages all right aging
aging and lifestyle through whole body
health God
uh Physicians formulated
using natural medical grade ingredients
neutral Falls drug-free patented
technology provides consistent reliable
results without compromising your sexual
health why have a full head of hair if
your dick's going to just be staring at
the floor
um
in a clinical study men showed
Progressive Improvement in hair growth
and thickness after three and six months
neutral Falls this is like a mini series
of hair growth neutral there's like two
more [__] three more paragraphs
neutrophone is also trusted and
recommended by more than 3 000 Top
Doctors I thought they said I thought
that said actors 3
000 top actors people like oh [__] the
movie stars are used in this I gotta get
some of this [__]
I'm not dude I say five A-list actors
are equal to three three thousand Top
Doctors
just to let the people in the marketing
department know when they put together
their memoir
uh you can grow thicker healthier hair
and support your own our show by going
to nutrifold.com
men and entering the promo code Burr to
save 15 it's raining hairy men
Hallelujah their dicks are hard they'll
bang their wives
um code bird to save 15 off first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it's only available to use
customers to us to U.S customers you
customers for a limited time
to use God Bill no because I was I was
I'm thinking of jokes I was just
thinking if you could get Viagra in
neutral fall
and you as you're growing your hair your
[__] dick is coming up I mean your
wife might faint that would be
incredible plus free shipping every
order get 15 off at neutral Falls
neutrophone.com slash men spelled
n-u-t-r-f
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
November uniform Tango Romeo Alpha
foxtrot Oscar
lima.com slash man promo code Burr
all right lastly but not leastly here
people oh would you look who there he is
there he is true bill there he is uh do
you know Nia do you know why free trials
renew without your consent no it's a
business scam out to get you don't let
greedy corporations pocket your money
download true bill to take control of
your subscriptions I love why don't they
just make it illegal that they can't do
oh because they pay all the politicians
true bill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about on average people
save up to 720 a year with true bill I
love this company yeah you sneaky
[__] bastards out there it's about
time somebody to catch us to catch a
sneak instead of a thief uh because
companies please look over my shoulder
so I don't [__] this up because
companies make subscriptions hard to
cancel true bill makes it incredibly
simple just link your accounts and true
bill will cancel your unwanted
subscriptions in one tap and true bill
and your true bill concierge good job
nailed that is there when you need them
to cancel unwanted subscriptions so you
don't have to true bill has over 2
million uses and helps save them over
100 million dollars
does that make sense on average 750
bucks times 2 million users
with the copy Bill like Matthew B says
oh Matthew B on the one and twos who
says in a matter of seconds I saved 660
dollars for the year on my DirecTV bill
oh [__] those sons of [__] saved 120
dollars for the year on my Sirius XM
build those [__] saved 840 a
year on car insurance those [__]
thieving
[__] uh don't fall for subscription
scams start canceling today at
truebill.com
go right now truebill.com
it could save you thousands a year
t-r-u-e-b-i-l-l.com slash Burr b-u-r-r
all right that's the podcast everybody
can I ask you a question yep do you miss
having hair
no yeah I don't either
I mean on you
I know you know what it is it's it's
when you hang on to it that's when you
miss it but I remember when you were
first talking about shaving your head I
was like no it and by that time you'd
already cut it down pretty low but I
still wasn't like you were the one who
told me to shave my head was that me
yeah oh okay
what am I talking about though I don't
know what you're talking about you were
like you would go shave your head shave
shave your head you would do that you're
right you're right you're right come on
it's time baby well you know what it was
let it go shave your head shave shave
your head come on now I like the middle
grounds
I think I like it either like ball ball
but when you were still like had a
little bit of hair like peach fuzz
that's what it was when I was like all
right let's just get rid of it all
no that's not what happened no when I
had it longer when I had the regular
size you were you said you shave your
head I say you think so you're like yeah
I was like I don't know I might look
like an [__] and you like shave your
head shave shave your head every [__]
day and I finally just trying to shut
you up
it's a good move though it was a good
move because you know what opportunities
exactly it's a weird thing man when you
when you have red hair on top of your
head they go you're you're you know
you're the nice guy you're the guys the
second you shave your head you're like
oh you're a [__] [__] it's like
I've been trying to tell you guys that
for 20 25 years I'm an [__] people
know
this is fun it was fun you have a better
relationship where you just know without
a doubt you love the other person more
than they love you
um all right this is the deal everybody
this podcast is done regardless of what
Nia is going to say after this please
enjoy the music from the great Andrew
femalis and we'll have a bonus episode
of the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday Morning podcast coming up
right after the music
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday
um what is today it's uh January 19th
ladies and gentlemen
I'm actually taping this on Sunday first
day
out I'm watching the uh Patriots right
now they're up 14-7
four minutes to go in the [__] fourth
second quarter Joe
Joe what are you what are you supposed
to be [__] Paul Revere
[__] goddamn Colonial hat
um
all right I gotta be honest with you
guys I already recorded a podcast this
week with a very special guest uh but
it's it's a famous drummer
and I think it's going to be too much of
a drum head thing for uh
all you guys are just like are used to
listening to me talk about sports so I'm
gonna do a quick one here Monday and
then I'm gonna have uh
I have an interview with Chris Layton
from uh Stevie Ray Vaughan and double
trouble back in the day from archangels
I saw him touring last year came through
the Greek with Kenny Wayne Shepherd he
does that Hendrix review thing and he's
actually in town here in La working with
Stephen Stills so uh if you're into
drums
and uh you know it's not not the only
thing that we talk about but we talk
about uh his time you know coming up and
making it and pushing through people
being negative a little talk about
Whiplash in there I think it's a really
interesting podcast even if you don't
play drums and uh he got me some
hilarious
a couple hilarious gifts and then one
unbelievable one because he's such a
great guy so please tune in I'll post
that probably on Wednesday of this week
so let's talk start talking some
make me a [__] sandwich lady please
um hey get in the kitchen and make me a
[__] sandwich you're watching a
goddamn game
you know what houses are so close
together out here I shouldn't be yelling
stuff like that you know I shouldn't you
yeah look at me again I'll give you
another one
let's see if I can get the cops coming
to my house
um I shouldn't do that like Eric blunt
for a first down sorry I'm not gonna do
that but I do have the game on here and
I actually have to uh
you know I got a ton of [__] I got to do
tomorrow so anyways
what do we do here what do we do um I
gotta tell you something right now I was
I watched the Green Bay Seattle game and
I am over it
but I was absolutely [__] sick at the
end of that game
um not out of like a hate in Seattle
kind of thing it was just
that [__] prevent defense prevent
offensing I just for the life of me
I mean it has to work
it has to it has to work not only has
does it have to work it has to work way
more times than it doesn't work for them
to continue the insanity
of playing football
for 50 [__] minutes 55 minutes and
then in the end you just play not to
lose that I
Green Bay went into Seattle
they shut up their crowd
they they handled
they manhandle them through the first
half
and then when you knew Seattle was going
to come back and have a surge and they
handled that
five minutes to go
they pick off Russell Wilson for the
fourth [__] time
you got the ball back all right
let's [__] eat up some clock
what do they do they run the ball into
the ass of their Center three [__]
times and then punt it
I didn't think they took a minute off
the clock
the whole game hey you got Aaron Rodgers
as a quarterback does he all of a sudden
not know how to throw a [__] ball
this guy's a Super Bowl champion do you
think he's [__] nervous
the whole game you're playing to win and
then in the end you I it was [__]
unbelievable I can't imagine what it'd
be like playing for the [__] Packers
Aaron Rodgers taking those play calls
you know
all right man five minutes to go what
are we doing here what are we gonna dump
it off to a running back we're gonna
post pattern what are we doing here
run the ball up the middle
oh okay all right yeah I get it burn a
little clock here ready ready
time out
two seconds three seconds off the clock
all right coach second down to ten what
are we doing huh we throwing the ball
here right what are we gonna do a little
play action fake freeze the linebackers
do something here maybe pick up five six
yards
run it up the middle
really all right hey you're the boss
[Music]
tackle time out
another two seconds off the [__]
clock
third down and ten
I don't even [__] Aaron's warming up
his arm what are we doing here come on
who am I throwing it to run it up the
middle
are you [__] serious
[__] are we doing right
you don't want to throw the ball
run it into the ass crap of your Center
this is a recording
blue 54.
that's it
over
Seattle doesn't take a timeout Green Bay
kicks the ball away they take off
[__] 50 seconds 55 seconds off the
clock then what do they do
are they going to go back to playing
football and get up in their grills
Rush [__] Russell Wilson put him on
his back like they have been the whole
guy [__] that
I got a better idea let's go into the
prevent
let's go into the [__] prevent
defense which is basically we don't want
to we don't want them to score on one
big play
we'll protect the sidelines we'll give
them the middle in 15 to 20 yard chunks
while they burn the clock or burn their
timeouts that's the philosophy so
basically you don't give it up on one
play
you give it up on sixth place and you
make every quarterback every quarterback
who's ever faced to prevent defense
immediately looked how Joe Montana or
John Elway
or Roger Staubach used to look when and
in the final two minutes of the game
when they actually played [__]
defense
as far as I remember
so Seattle goes right you know you know
what the and I am literally where's my
phone I [__] was texting Paul verzi
you want to hear my tweets during the
end of this [__] game
all right here we go
let me scroll Jesus they're coming in
chunks coming in chunks
let's see here all right this is me
after I watch them run the ball into the
ass of their [__] Center three plays
in a row and then punted all capitals
what a [__] waste of a possession
they are now going to ruin it oh not
that they're all I think they still had
one more run to go they are now going to
run it
that just got Seattle's just gonna take
a time out [__] eight seconds off the
clock now they've kicked the ball I
write what was the strategy there
get the other team to use all their
timeouts they aren't even going to burn
a minute off the clock on four [__]
plays Paul writes back I know now
Seattle has the ball and I text they are
literally going to get they're going to
give this team a touchdown just so they
can burn off time from the clock I can't
tell if that is good coaching or it is
done by the league to give every game
possible a dramatic ending this is when
I'm sitting there going I'm a comedian
what the [__] do I know
about about prevent defense all I know
is a fan watching now obviously they
scored I wrote [__] joke
first he wrote wow then he said no TD
thank god oh that's when they threw it
to Marshawn Lynch
who by the way is the closest thing I've
seen since Earl Campbell watching an
entire defense try to tackle that man is
like you haven't been drunk with your
friends during the summertime and all
the windows of your car is down and you
got everybody gets out of the car on a
small hill and all of a sudden you
notice the car starts rolling and
everybody grabs onto it sliding in the
tennis shoes trying to stop it
eventually you [__] do that's what
it's like watching a defense try and
stop Marshawn Lynch It's [__] amazing
um
then I go every [__] game Paul every
[__] game that stupid strategy makes
every team look like the 49ers in 1989.
um
okay now Green Bay okay they now I don't
want to read all this whole [__]
thing it's just basically
I'll read the excerpts it's the dumbest
[__] strategy I've ever seen in my
life Green Bay Packers deserve this
their fans don't
in the end travesty
and verse he said the problem was they
kicked they gut field goals instead of
touchdowns there's nothing wrong with
that if you're playing against the
defense I feel as good as Seattle's you
got to take what they're gonna give you
all right you kick the field goals and
then your defense was answering the call
they answered the belt whatever the
[__] cliche is and you had the
[__] game one
Green Bay had the ball back they had the
ball they had their [__] Destiny in
their hands go for a first down they if
they got two first downs three first
downs that [__] game is over
sorry I'm back I'm back I actually
knocked my record off I was saying I'm
so [__] old that when I see people
who run like me how bad I run they've
played 17 years of quarterback and blew
out an ACL
um
anyway so I at the end of the game
watching them
watching them lose
that game the way they did
first of all congrats I didn't even say
congratulations to Seattle
congratulations I mean you
it's not your fault they stop [__]
playing and I guess to say that I'm
taking away from your Victory but I'm
sure you've seen your team I think every
football fan you've seen your team
do that
you've seen your team just playing
football I'm not giving up an inch I'm
right up on you [__] this we're winning
this game and then you go to this whole
like well you know I'll give you like
we'll give you 10 yards 15 yards but
that's it I mean just it's just the
exact
I I don't know the mentality of it I I
just don't
I don't understand it it makes you know
what it is about the prevent defense no
game is Out Of Reach
you have to be like [__] up 21 points
but if it's below 20
all of a sudden within five minutes
If You're Gonna Play that way it just
seems like everything all of a sudden is
in reach
and then the announcers like a
Dramatical turn of my life who never
thought what
when you start playing 20 yards off a
guy
when you stop calling any imaginative
plays on offense and even Troy Aikman on
the third time was going like you know I
gotta feel like they're gonna run it
here keep it on the ground it's like
everybody knew it
when you got two stand-up comedians
texting what the Green Bay Packers are
gonna do next that's probably not a good
sign as far as if you're going to try
and win a [__] game
dude I was so
I was so upset
because I felt like the pain you know
I'm not looking past the Colts either I
know obviously anything can happen but
if we were going to go to the Super Bowl
um
I gotta think that uh
for whatever reason we matched up better
with Green Bay I just
I just feel that the fact that we get
for the most part no pressure on the
quarterback
and you got Russell who's so mobile
um that would present a problem and then
we suck against the Run for the most
part and Marshawn Lynch even if you're
good against them it takes at least what
like six seven people just to kind of
slow them down
and Seattle's defense is unbelievable as
annoying as they are how they stand over
every person after they tackle them as
if that person has never been tackled
before
and as in knowing as all those bandwagon
fans are which was hilarious to see them
locked out you know nobody who was at
the Kingdome back in the day left that
game you know God damn well they're
going to stay there even if they were
going to lose they would have sat there
and they would have cried like a real
fan and then walked out to your car with
your head down well it was always next
year right
um
I have a tremendous amount of respect
for uh for that organization I mean it's
a [__] I mean obviously the teams
that they put together is incredible
um but I would like to win the Super
Bowl so I would like to give my team the
greatest chance so I was uh that was not
the damn team that I wanted to play
but
um it's not even that the Seattle won it
was the Way Green Bay lost and I I had
to get in my [__] Prius
[__] go for a drive
and um
I ended up at an Italian restaurant
they they make homemade pasta right and
I was right before dinner and they
hadn't made they were in the process of
making the pasta in their sauce so I got
on this I got a salad and then just a
couple of meatballs and sat there and
had a scotch as the Patriots were
playing recording the game
um
just dumbfounded how I watched Green Bay
lose that [__] game
and uh
and somewhere halfway through that
Scotch that I was drinking it just
became hilarious
that my team was playing and I was so
distraught over two other teams that
aren't my team
that didn't knock my team out and that I
wasn't even watching my team even though
I was recording it
and just that whole thing
of like why the [__] why do I care this
much
and um
I don't know it just kind of struck me
as funny
then of course I'm talking to the
bartender you know he doesn't give a
[__] about
well I guess maybe he could give a [__]
he just needed money so he was working I
just assume if you're taking that shift
you could at least fake sick or whatever
um
so
anyways uh Jesus Christ
two weeks in a row
at least it wasn't a bad call man but
what the [__]
what the [__] anyways this is the Monday
Morning podcast
um
I don't have any uh any questions or
anything this week how far into this I
don't even know how many [__] minutes
I'm into this because I didn't look at
the first one should probably uh my
condolences
not only to Packer fans but any fan of a
[__] team that had to sit there and
watch your team have a game one and then
go into the prevent defense I I'm really
actually going to listen to Sports Talk
Radio tomorrow morning
to try and have some hopefully somebody
will explain it
um
there's another one I don't get
five seconds left in the half for some
[__] reason
you squib kick it
so then they get the ball in the 40.
like how big a threat is that guy back
in the end zone what are the odds he's
going to take it to the 40.
if they wanted to they probably won't
but if they wanted to they could just
[__] heave it to the end zone with
Andrew Luck's arm right
I don't know I don't [__] get it
um well Bill you're a comedian you're
not supposed to get it oh go [__]
yourself
um so anyways I got a uh I got a crazy
week coming up here
um if you guys remembered a long time
ago I did a movie out in uh New Orleans
called Black or White that started oh
they took a knee
it's another thing why don't you throw
the Hail Mary
they used to do that what is the problem
um anyways I really sound like a crabby
old man why don't they don't
they don't used to do it
uh all right so I did a movie a year and
a half ago
uh called Black or White
um starring Kevin Costner
Octavius Spencer and uh directed and
written by Mike binder
um
and it's finally coming out it's coming
out on January 30th
and uh so we're doing all the promotion
all the press and all that type of stuff
this week which should be uh hopefully a
good time so I got a bunch of that type
of [__] coming up and uh I'm gonna be on
um
Real Time with Bill Maher
on uh on Friday and uh and then after
that on Saturday I leave for my uh
where the hell am I going I go to
Australia
New Zealand Singapore Hong Kong Mumbai
all of that [__] and I get back to just
going back to being a comedian so I got
basically a week of press here that I'm
doing coming up
um I was in New Orleans this week
I did a
had a quick three-day shoot
and uh an upcoming movie I never say
what they are until they're coming out
and then I make sure that I'm still in
them so uh
you know trying to keep my actor health
insurance hanging in there the SAG after
[__] so uh anyways let's do a little bit
of advertising here for this week uh
what do we got here vegas.com
for my listeners ten percent off
everything excluding air hotel packages
oh so you basically got to get yourself
there and put yourself up and then
everything else is 10 off go to
vegas.com right now when you book hotels
show shows and activities get 10 off
when you enter my code Burr b-u-r-r they
really do serve up Vegas from the inside
because unlike other travel sites they
are from Vegas
these are not Outsiders these people are
down there
all right
everyone at vegas.com lives in Vegas
Works in Vegas parties in Vegas
pukes in Vegas
top 10 Vegas must Do's take a photo at
the welcome to Fabulous Las Vegas Nevada
sign you got to do that shoot a zombie
in the face goes without saying drive a
really fast car
sounds like gonna drive a car really
fast I should say sounds like they're
going to take you to that racetrack out
there jump off the stratosphere that's
debatable experience Elvis of course be
a rock star for the day why not hang out
at a topless optional Pool Club creepy
dance like a stripper get married at
Denny's enter my code Burr b-u-r in the
promo code at checkout and get an extra
10 off everything but air hotel packages
that's vegas.com and get your bonus
savings with my secret code that I'm
telling everybody so it's no longer a
secret consider yourself on the inside
Burr b-u-r-r all right National Academy
of sports medicine
they're here exclamation point New
Year's resolutions period everyone's got
one exclamation point get in shape dot
dot dot be healthier dot dot dot get a
new job dot dot dot become a certified
personal trainer with the National
Academy of sports medicine and you can
do all three the fitness industry is
booming of course it is baby boomers are
still on treadmills you know they're
blowing out their knees and their hips
they're getting the plantar fasciitis
whatever the hell it is the fitness
industry is booming in the demand for
personal training is soaring I can't
feel my leg imagine waking up every day
excited by the fact that people are hurt
and you're going to make money off of
them
not a job but a rewarding career getting
paid to stay in shape while helping
others to reach their fitness goals oh
this is oh these are personal trainers
I don't know what I'm selling here I'm a
[__]
um
uh you set your own hours you work in
health clubs Sports clinics and Corp
corporate wellness and you'll love who
you work with finally do what you truly
enjoy and get paid for it this is a
pretty cool job get ahead stat on 2015
and bring in your certification with the
National Academy of sports medicine now
if you don't land a job as a personal
trainer within 60 days of certification
they'll give you your money back
guaranteed oh it's a personal trainer
sorry geez that's pretty cool huh if you
don't get a job in two months call to
action go to myusatrainer.com for a free
14-day sneak peek of their fast and fun
online program that's myusatrainer.com
myusatrainer.com
restrictions apply visit my
usatrainer.com for details and then the
last one here I'm going to read
draftkings.com your season ending long
fantasy football league may be over but
there's plenty of excitement sorry had a
scotch but there's plenty of excitement
every week at DraftKings banks.com true
story Dave from Boston won a million
dollars in one day just playing fantasy
football so did Matt from Florida
and Ray from New Jersey Ray I heard you
one [__] a million you mean zero you
fat [__] in fact DraftKings has crowned
a new millionaire nearly every week this
season the football action even
continues throughout the playoffs at
draftkings.com and be sure to check out
their exciting money making contests and
other sports too like hockey and college
and pro hoops
you've been hearing about big winners at
DraftKings all year now it's your turn
to win huge cash well now it's your turn
to try to win huge cash or you could
give up your money and be part of that
mountain of cash that they keep and they
divvy off a little bit to one lucky
winner evidently someone from Florida
call to action head to draftkings.com
now and use a promo code defense
to play for free and hundreds of
thousands of dollars and 100 and the
hundred thousand dollar fantasy football
contest this weekend draftkings.com
bigger events bigger winners bigger
millionaires enter defense for every
entry now at draftkings.com
draftkings.com what is that everybody
say with me draftkings.com
all right let's go back to this um oh I
did another one of the goddamn comedy
jams
uh this weekend with Josh Adam Meyers
and uh we actually did um I did a
Pantera song uh Cowboys from health
was the song that I chose to do uh
despite the fact that I don't play
double bass and uh my double bass
playing was was uh was pretty horrific
but it was way better than I was before
I decided to do that song
um I dressed up like Vinnie Paul
I made an ass of myself and uh but it's
fun you know what's cool was I sat down
behind the kid I wasn't nervous at all
which is uh which is a good thing
because usually there's a um
you know because I'm stepping outside
myself but you know you just keep doing
it and doing it doing and all of a
sudden just becomes oh yeah I'm doing
this show again I've done it before I
know what I gotta do
blah blah blah blah and uh
you know what's funny the sound was
really bad we were outside in a tent
it's way better when it's when they have
the show over on La Brea because you can
actually you know the sound is
tremendous they had to turn down the
sound because we were playing Riot Fest
some sort of Comedy Festival that they
have in downtown L.A and people were
complaining about the noise not even
from the music they were complaining
about how loud the stand-ups were I
guess there was a uh apartment building
right next door
so my apology to those people but um
yeah I went up there and I had a I had a
good time so I have no idea what the
next one I'm gonna do is
if you guys have any requests
you know if you have I'm basically
asking you guys to give me an idea
of what song I should [__] play next
because uh
I'm kind of out of ideas I played a
zeppelin one dressed like John Bonham
Motley Crue Tommy Lee and now I did
Pantera
um
I don't know I don't know I don't want
to let the double bass go I don't want
to do another another double bass song
but if anybody knows a good one
uh if you learned how to play double
bass obviously starting with Vinnie Paul
is not an easy thing if you know a
Pantera song that uh
because if you play double bass I would
imagine that Cowboys from Hell is pretty
straightforward
um as far as the tempo is not that bad
if you know something else along those
lines that's sort of the next thing
because I always felt like if you're
learning how to play drums for me if you
learn if you're a white guy and you're
playing Rock drums for me it was you
started with AC DC
right you learn the whole four on the
floor two four [__] thing right and
then the next thing I would do is then
you move to Like Guns and Roses Appetite
for Destruction
or maybe you even went up to Charlie
Watts if you're gonna baby step your way
up so it's a little more busy bass drum
you know and uh then I would go Appetite
for Destruction and then from there
it would basically be like whatever
Direction you wanted to go in
and here I am talking about drums again
I'm not supposed to be talking about I
mean what the [__] I'm supposed to be
talking about here
um anyways hey I saw that movie Boyhood
did you guys see that [__]
it's pretty interesting where they have
uh
basically they shot the movie over 12
years and you get to watch this little
boy that they cast grow up oh my God
here we go again domestic violence and
sexual assaults are hard subjects for
everyone to talk about so let's show all
these people crying
when people get around raped
who does
what are they going to do next funerals
where you actually cared about the
person who died are hard to talk about
and then I have to watch people crying
for the love of God who are those
[__] commercials for
does the person who sexually assault
someone just sees Hillary Swank crying
and then goes you know what I'm gonna
stop sexually assaulting people
I don't I don't for the [__] life of
me
who doesn't care about victims
of basically anything
did what are they are they trying to
move me to do what what are they trying
to do I think they're trying to get my
money on some level
right
so that they can siphon off 20 of it so
they can go out and go buy themselves a
pink Bentley and then they throw some
money at the uh you know no more
backhands.org whatever the [__] they're
doing I just for the life of me those
[__] goddamn commercials
and as annoying as those are I don't
understand why you kick another team's
[__] ass for 55 minutes and then
decide to lay down on the goddamn ground
for the final your own choice
your own [__] choice
um
God damn it I liked it I like Seattle I
really like that [__] team but I just
cannot stand all the [__] Pomp and
Circumstance around it did you guys see
that they have two giant screams
allegedly measuring how loud the [__]
crowd is I mean isn't it enough that
they built a [__] Stadium to try to
just hold those people's hands into
trying to sound like they give a [__]
what else do they have to do to coerce
these people into cheering every goddamn
game they got to have some [__] war
vet or [__] 80 at 1980s Action Hero
come out and wave a [__] hanky to get
them all excited you're not excited
it's a [__] playoff game
you're gonna try to be the first team to
repeat in like 10 [__] years that's
not enough excitement
you know you need Frank Stallone to come
out there and swing a dirty diaper over
his [__] oh yeah that's right we're
supposed to give a [__]
ugh
worst dressed fans
who are you going with honorary mentions
got to be the black hole Oakland Raiders
that absolute [__] [__] show of
humanity
I would say Cleveland Browns the dog
pound if they put him on TV more
remember that when they used to bark at
the camera and eating dog biscuits and
you're supposed to sit at home going wow
these people are crazy
they had money legal tender to buy
football tickets and they went to their
assigned seat
uh Jesus [__] Christ with the pretend
crazy I gotta be honest with you the
person who's really just gonna [__]
knock you out and make you [__] you
know
eat the rest of your meals for the rest
of your life sipping through a [__]
straw is not the guy that's dressed up
like a dog
or the dude with the spikes coming out
of his [__] shoulder pads it's gonna
be that quiet guy with the dirty hat
[Music]
the dude with the neck tattoo it's gonna
be that person
because they know that they're crazy and
they know that they're going to [__]
somebody up and the last thing they want
to do is [__]
put somebody in a coma and then run out
of a stadium dress like big bird because
they're gonna get caught they they wanna
they wanna blend in with the [__]
crowd
wouldn't you think
am I out of my mind to think that [__] I
have no idea so anyways I just heard a
[__] plane fly over my head I'm
actually studying
for my exam next month to get my uh my
license and I'm not going to fly here
for the next uh
a couple of weeks due to my schedule and
all that type of [__] so I am literally
studying
um bringing my notebooks with me taking
practice tests
oh [__] I should have had some of that
stuff in front of me
I should have taken one of those goddamn
tests all this type of [__] you have to
know
if you're flying east to west and you
slow down
you know which way is the needle gonna
point is it going to point down towards
the south of the north on your [__]
compass
I already can't even [__] remember
I've answered that question so many
[__] times I still forget
when you're flying East when you fly
east to west
you fly
at an even altitude Plus 500.
west to east you fly at an odd
plus 500 so you wouldn't fly at five
thousand you'd fly at fifty five hundred
if you're going the other way you'd fly
four thousand five hundred not four
thousand all of that [__] plus all this
[__] about the weather
all right what do you got here second
half is starting
how about [__] Amendola has this guy
been stepping up or what I was like most
people I thought the guy like every time
he went to go pick up his helmet he blew
out his hamstring and all of a sudden I
mean he had such a [__] I didn't
really talk about the game last week
I was so [__] uh on my period about
the Dez Bryant
catch that wasn't a catch and uh
I don't know what am I gonna learn I
can't [__] have the TV on and try to
[__] Riff on this goddamn thing you
would think oh by the way can we talk
about that lady
the [__] wait
there's a woman out there
um she [__] was married to a guy who
was a billionaire she's getting a
divorce the guy wrote her a check just
under a billion dollars and she turned
it down
now I know what a lot of people are
thinking what a [__] gold digging
[__]
this is right up Bill's alley
I know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna tweet
a [__] link to this article and this
will get him going on the podcast and
then he'll have a [__] fit and I'll
laugh as I'm sitting in my cubicle well
surprise surprise
I'm not really having a [__] fit about
this because I don't think it's about
the money
this is the deal this Broad
all right this [__] Twinkle Toes here
all right all little [__] sugar tits
here she married this guy this guy was
worth 50 million bucks he was an oil man
get off my [__] property
there ain't no global warming
good I like that there's a hole in the
ozone layer makes me feel like I'm
closer to God right he's an oil man
hey I'll tell you what Mr President I
don't even know why I have to call you
Mr President I [__] put you in office
with my Goddamn money look at me when
I'm talking to you Obama
all right
my granddaddy put that dictator in
[__] power and he was supposed to
give us our little gold little [__]
there right he's supposed to give us our
liquid gold right he ain't doing it no
more you got to go over there you got to
take that [__] out you understand me I
don't give a [__] how you do it he's an
oil man
it's a [__] Oil Man
all right he's got Slim Whitman
on LaserDisc
right
that's Irish what was the [__] Slim
Whitman he sold over 9 million records
um anyways I'm all over the [__] map
here see I'm back to me I'm not looking
at the TV anymore
um
so this [__] guy he's got he's got a
50 million dollar business
he already has this and this woman does
not sign a [__] it he doesn't sign a
prenup with the woman
according to her she didn't take the
billion dollar payout because now 26 27
28 [__] years later they're going for
divorce this guy's company is worth 20
billion dollars according to her
all right
now here's the thing she's like I was
with this guy and I supported him and
held down the [__] home front and all
that that's got to be worth something
this was [__] crazy to me it's like
you know with all due respect sweetheart
this guy made 50 million without you
okay
look I could see if the guy had a couple
hundred grand in the bank all right
maybe all right whatever
you know what I mean
if you make 50 million dollars give me a
[__] break if you started out with
nothing and you're worth 50 million
dollars you [__] you know what you're
doing
at that point once you have 50 million
dollars that's that's when that's when
you got your own you're starting to have
your own plane
you're in a gated community you got your
own security system you know you [__]
kill somebody and the cops go down to
your house and they're talking to your
lawyer in the driveway is just sitting
there eating [__] escargo in an
English muffin and they're asking your
[__] lawyer if you if you wouldn't
mind turning yourself in over the next
six seven days you like that level
[__] rich and once you're that level
Rich it's all [__] downhill
you're meeting the people that are
running the world
you meet the people in the Bilderberg
Group you meet the people in the other
groups that I don't know about or what
the [__] they talk about but I pretend
like I do you're at that level of
[__] wealth
all right
so this [__] guy grows it to 20
billion dollars and she gets a check for
a billion basically
and uh she says she doesn't want it
she wants more so everybody's saying
that she's a gold digging [__] you know
what I really think it is
and she's saying that she supported them
and helped them build say go [__]
yourself all right
let's let's just say for whatever
[__] reason I met an unknown Lady
Gaga in the East Village 10 12 [__]
years ago
right and she's down there ripping off
Madonna songs or whatever and I'm like
you know what there's something about
her though you know she's got nice legs
she's got a nice ass I mean I like the
imperfections I like the giant nose look
at me I got red [__] hair it's
falling out I think we can make a good
couple
you know we're both a mess two negatives
make it positive we'll make a beautiful
baby so I start [__] hanging out with
her next thing you know we fall in love
Garrett blood oh [__]
um
so then we think uh all right
you know we get married
okay and let's just say whatever I'm
doing I'm [__] I make keys that's
what I do that's my job okay and she's
out down there she's down the village
and she's [__] you know she's making
her own meat dress you know
she's going out she's making money in a
coffee house and she goes right to the
deli and she buys more meat she's
investing in herself she's building her
career she's playing the [__] piano
she's coming home and she's like what do
you think of this and I'm like it sounds
good honey right I'm over there I'm
knitting a [__] sweater
you know I got a pot roast in the
goddamn oven or whatever okay and then
she becomes Lady Gaga I get to quit my
[__] job
um Mr Gaga
I get to go on Oprah and sit there
silently you know
as Oprah talks to lady for [__] an
hour and then finally she says well what
what do you seeing her and then I
already have some pre-written speech
about how I'm Gaga about Gaga I'm Gaga
for Gaga whatever the [__] happens right
and let's just say in the end all of
that I'm walking down the [__] Hall
blinded by her Gold Records platinum
records and all that [__] every morning
when I go to brush my teeth I gotta
[__] I gotta put on my uh my Amber
Visions just to get there so I don't
[__] walk into the walk-in closet
instead of the bathroom
let's say at the end of that she gets
sick of me and she kicks me to the
[__] curb
all right now let's say she's worth 100
million dollars and she turns around and
says I'm gonna give you Bill I'm gonna
write you a check
let's do the same thing let's just say
to 20 billion just say she's worth 20
million and she says Bill I'm going to
give you a million dollars
and you know what I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say thank you Lady Gaga
that was awesome
I enjoy I was just making keys I wasn't
going to make a million dollars in my
lifetime
all right I'm going to take this money
and I'm going to pay my taxes on it I'm
going to get myself a little [__]
house
you know and I'm going to make keys in
the back of it I'm going to get my life
back and I'm going to find God knows you
gave me plenty of [__] and I would buy
you know what I would do with that I
would go buy a [__] everybody needs Keys
touchdown Patriots
who the [__] was that
we've just scored that
Nate Solder just scored his first
touchdown ever
nice 23 7. oh did we match up better
against the Packers
so anyway oh look at our look at two
cheaters talking there
on the sidelines two convicted cheetahs
that was a nice play that was a nice
play how'd you like the video I love the
video
um anyways you gotta have a sense of
humor but you don't [__] team don't
you most people don't but I do
um anyways
so let's go back here uh
yeah she gave me a million bucks what I
would do is I would find a house
that cost like I don't know like 150
Grand
you know and I would put down a
ridiculous amount of money on it
and then I put the rest of the money
away and I would start cutting Keys
again out of the back of my house
and I get that business going and I
would [__] Build It Up
and then I go on to uh
instead of farmersonly.com I'd go on
like uh keymakers only.com and I try to
meet somebody else that's what the [__]
I would do I would never try to take her
money I'd be like you know what I know I
gave you support
I know I said that was a beautiful song
I know you wrote a couple songs about us
instead of deer Ben you wrote dear bill
I get it
but I can't sing I can't play a [__]
piano who's kidding hoe we both know why
I lived the life I lived for the last 10
years it was because of you Lady Gaga
and to think I got to live that life and
in the end of it you're going to give me
a million bucks to leave yeah you're a
[__] saint
I still love you lady Gaga even though
you don't love me anymore I get it
I don't even know why you love me in the
first place but God Bless you that's
probably why you write such wonderful
songs that connects with an entire
demographic of people
continued success
thank you for that million dollars
and I would [__] leave
right
I got too much [__] Pride to sit
there if somebody doesn't [__] want
me
to then try to take everything they got
I mean just I couldn't find the second
someone didn't want me around like all
right Jesus I didn't know I was annoying
you
I get it sorry
can I grab my things now do you want to
want me to send somebody else I just get
the [__] out of there
um
so anyway so that seems to be you know
this lady here that she she got a
billion dollars
um and she says it's not enough
what I honestly think it is I just think
it's an emotional thing for this woman I
don't think it's a money thing
because you can't spend that you can't
spend all that [__] money
right
did you guys they actually showed a copy
of the uh of the check
that this dude wrote
to his ex-wife he didn't write it on one
of those business checks you know that
are sort of extra long and the whole
extra area of the memo section that you
write stuff he wrote it on like a
personal little check like the same kind
of check like you know somebody living
week to week one of those little
checkbooks he wrote a check for like 989
million
899 thousand dollars and 31 cents
whatever the [__] it was
and I think what he did was
this guy's obvious I don't know what the
[__] maybe he's just good at business I
think he just sat down
after they decided on the number and I
bet he did it right in front of her
after 26 [__] years
okay
he's walking away
he's leaving and he just sits down
and he's just writing money just to make
her leave
and he just sits down and goes scribble
scribble scribble sign sign sign dot the
I cross the [__] team tears it out of
here go beat it lady I just think it
came across like that and it [__]
pisses her off
and she's just like this is the thing of
the worst thing you could have when a
woman's breaking up with you or if
you're breaking up with a woman is if
she's not over you if she's over you
it's gonna go smoothly you don't have to
deal with her [__] you know put
enough your pet rabbit and a goddamn
stew all right but if they're not over
you you gotta [__] let them down easy
you can't just push them down the
emotional Elevator Shaft
all right you're gonna have a major
[__] problem and I think this guy he
just [__] fired off the check like he
was paying another bill
and I she just was insulted by that and
she's think doing the math in her head
like you know this motherfucker's gonna
I actually talked a little bit about
this on the Chris Layton podcast so I
forgive me if there's a little bit of
overlap but I just want to hear what he
thought about it
um
I think that uh
I
I don't know I just think that they they
want you
they want you to hurt
they just want you to hurt I don't know
what it is not all of them just some of
them and I think that she didn't get as
sad as enough of a satisfied hurt look
on this guy's face
there wasn't enough pain
I think he just treated her like he had
to get the gutters fixed and had some
professional come over and did it he
just fired off this [__] check and it
just pissed her off
now because she's more than taken care
of for the rest of her [__] life
anything she could ever want she's it's
all good
but I think the fact that he still has
so much more money and it didn't hurt
him to write that check
that and she knows that he has enough
money to get like you know
I mean you got 20
billion dollars there's like a
Victoria's Secret model that will
pretend to give a [__] about you for a
good year year and a half and you can do
that for the rest of your life as you
ride around in Ferraris now her she's a
woman guys don't work that way we don't
really give a [__] about money
you know we're more like enamored by
looks
you know it's both of our [__]
weaknesses whatever you guys are into
stuff we're into [__] uh
you know tits and ass so which is why
you know we will date somebody as dumb
as a [__] rock and you will also
date some ugly old balding douche you
know
because they can take care of you it's
it's kind of what we do so I'm not
really a lot of people wanted me to go
off on her like she's a gold digging
horror I don't think she is I think
she's I think she's hurt
and uh she's heard how easy this guy is
just getting over I know all you guys
are sitting there going like dude what
the [__] he's right now check for
billion dollars I know that hurts dude
you got 20 billion dollars come on man
if that's true
if it's true and you got 20 billion
dollars
yeah I'll write you a [__] check for
for a bill that wouldn't hurt me at all
there you go bang bang boom Beat It
Whistling Dixie Jesus Christ the [__]
interest alone on that money you by the
time you walk down the driveway
or she walks down the driveway leaving
you your money is probably already made
[__] 30 million dollars what the [__]
do you care
um I know he's probably that's obviously
not 20 billion liquid it's got a lot of
that tied up and Derrick's right some
giant [__] ranches some oil rags
trucks
um
look at that Pat's fan
that look like Jim laletta
um comedian I I knew back in Boston uh
drinking a Sam Adams there
anyways it's 24-7
909 left to go in the third quarter
Patriots D is looking good but I I just
don't think there's anything in the AFC
that was is really going to uh
can get you ready for what Seattle's
gonna be bringing on a d at least a
defensive level uh
I don't know that was probably one of
the worst games as a pro that Russell
Wilson has had I have no I really don't
have I don't have any idea
on what's going to happen I like if the
Patriots play Seattle in the Super Bowl
it will not surprise me if we win or we
get absolutely ass raped I have no
[__] idea I've watched that little
amount of football
um
this year because I've been so [__]
busy
um
but that's going to be amazing and how
about Robert Kraft huh I know I've
mentioned this before what a [__]
owner he is three coaching hires Bill
Parcells unknown Pete Carroll as far as
like at the pro level and then Bill
Belichick
and it's pretty cool that now his uh
he's basically these two guys are
looking like they're gonna face each
other in the Super Bowl uh uh I would
love to hear that conversation I wonder
if I wonder if they've ever talked since
he fired him I'm sure he sent him some
sort of [__]
um
what the [__] was it 1-800 fruit what
was that thing when I lost my [__] when
I was reading it I can't remember what
the [__] was it
fruitbaskets.org I forget uh me undies
everybody here we go again me undies me
undies no more sweaty balls me undies me
undies you can buy them at the [__]
mall walk up to a [__] chick you
don't have to worry that your dick's
gonna stick oh you are wearing [__]
me undies you got no sweaty balls oh
yeah you can talk to the [__] chick
without dripping get yourself some no
more sweaty balls
ninety percent that's the percent of
your life that you're in your underwear
there right
um and underwear gets old fast you know
that feeling of putting on old saggy
underwear you need to know the feeling
of great fitting underwear that is two
times softer than cotton you need to
know about me undies me undies no more
sweaty balls me undies.com meundy says
the most comfortable underwear you will
ever wear
four out of five ball bags say we love
me undies and it's insane how good they
make you feel they fit perfectly they
don't ride up on you [__] ass crack
and they literally pull moisture away
from your skin gross so you can stay
cool
personalized
I have mine on right now I didn't I had
him on earlier
and I am floating I wouldn't say I'm
floating but I was comfortable you know
what I wore them last night when I was
pretending to be Vinnie Paul and that's
the best I ever played live and who am I
giving credit to
Josh Adam Myers nope me undies me undies
I'm [__] butchering double bass uh I
can't even tell you how great I feel
when I'm staying cool and comfortable
down there all day oh these are all
examples of stuff that I'm supposed to
say it's such a profound impact to the
way I feel it don't say impact around
your balls anyways they're great I've
tried them on Grog for a first down I've
tried them they have cool styles for
both men and ladies oh good me
underneath
no more clammy [__] oh yeah and look
great check out the photos yourself at
meundies.com this quality would
typically retail for two times the
meandi price according to them no retail
middlemen means more savings to you here
I'll make it easy go to meandis.com and
get 20 off your first order for free and
free shipping save even more when you
buy a pack of them they guarantee you're
going to be happy with them or your
first pair is free I gotta tell you I've
worn them uh they're great they're nice
and thin too you know what I mean
they're not cumbersome so if you if
you're one of those people that wears
your hipster jeans
you know where they're tight yet sagging
off your lack of an ass I think that
this is the underwear for you
and they come in very bright noticeable
notice my ass colors I think I think I
think they're the perfect underwear for
you all right stamps.com everybody trips
to the post office are never convenient
so why not get postage right from your
desks with stamps.com stamps.com even
gives you special post special postage
discounts you you can't get at the post
office including first class Priority
Mail Express International and more
you'll never have to pay full price for
postage again here's how stamps.com
Works everybody
oh first no no first down [__]
Brandon Lafell
um here we go
here's how stamps.com Works using your
own computer and printer buy and print
official U.S postage for any letter or
package they just hand your mail to the
mailman or drop it in in a mailbox [__]
I got the hiccups now it's just that
easy
it's no wonder over 500 000 small
businesses are already using stamps.com
I use stamps.com anytime I make a post
poster to send out to people
to send out the venue so I can sell them
to people at the end of the show and I'm
a [__] if I can figure out how to use
it so can you right now use my last name
Burr b u r r to get this special offer
no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
free postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in Burr b-u-r-r that's
stamps.com enter Burr
Dollar Shave Club dough
you know I just realized how spoiled I
am as a fan
that we are up by 17 points and I'm
sitting here doing a podcast with the
game on mute in the background we've
gone to so many [__] Super Bowls I
mean it's it's [__] ridiculous I need
to I need to appreciate this more I
think that was a first down wasn't it
all depends on when they blow the
whistle all right Dollar Shave Club
everybody can someone tell me when
razors got so goddamn expensive if I
have been asleep for 20 years is that
what happened
I was in a store the other day and one
pack of razors is now 20 bucks one pack
people that is crazy but hey sometimes
they give you a free gift when you buy
their overpriced razors which is Ash
which is actually just a punch in the
dick
financially speaking that is don't get
beat up by ridiculous razor prices get
your shave gear where I get mine from
dollarshaveclub.com for just a few bucks
dollar shaveclub.com delivers amazing
razors and other great grooming supplies
right to your doorstep I'm waiting for
them to Dollar Shave Club to make a hot
comb for your pubes
up
laughs
do a little Frederick Frederick Douglass
down there surprise the ladies
um their plan starts at just three
dollars here's how it works they sent me
the candle for free and every month they
send me replacement blades it's one less
thing to worry about you can get
deliveries every month or every other
month however the hell you want to do it
they got lots of other grooming supplies
too you know I love the one wipe
Charlie's oh yeah
uh sorry I just watched Edelman catch a
pass Why Pay twenty dollars for Raiders
Raiders for razors when you can get the
Fantastic shave from dollarshaveclub.com
for a fraction of the price stop getting
smacked around by high razor prices
dollarshaveclub.com razors are great and
they are a fraction of the price trust
me you wish you've done it sooner don't
be a dumbass shave smada go to
dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com you know I have to
say it three times say with me
dollarshaveclub.com
all right hey how about those Bruins huh
they finally for the first time this
year
put together a nice run there they uh
they played six games without losing
winning five in a row and they lost one
in overtime but they still picked up a
point then last uh the other night they
lost to the Columbus Blue Jackets but uh
they're starting to hopefully play up to
uh
up to their potential I love whenever
whenever they have a [__] problem do
you know somebody actually texted me and
they said that they should trade luchich
or trade Brad Marshawn it's like yada
you [__] mind
yeah let's trade the guys to get the
[__] team going
you know
I just for the life of me I just don't
understand the panic
and they always pick like the star I
think people who say that just they
don't watch the game
they just [__] they just they watch
the Stars like if the Patriots start
losing this remember earlier this year
they started blaming Tom Brady saying
he's is he passed his prime
um I didn't think that but I was also
one of those people that thought I
thought the Patriots were finished after
that uh
was it Kansas City game and then we came
against the Bengals I I thought it was
um
I definitely thought that we were done
um because I just felt like we kept uh
I think you can hear it on one of my
podcasts I was saying how we had this
formula
where we would basically
have a veteran player and right when the
guy was getting his second or his second
to last or his last contract and he
wanted big money we would always trade
the person away
to stay under the cap or whatever and
then we would place them with somebody
that didn't have experience and then
we'd be weak at that position for a
while we just kept doing that all the
way around on offensive defense and I I
don't know trading Logan Mankins look
like a bad [__] move
but the genius of Belichick and the
driver Brady
um and the defense and all that I was
wrong
so
I've been wrong about a lot of [__] and
I don't think we match up well against
Seattle so I think I've
I'm hoping I'm going to be wrong against
that granted there's still you know
plenty of [__] time left in this game
I'm talking about it like we already
want
um anyways how far into this are we 46
minutes I forget how long I talked in
the other one I feel like I gotta talk
to at least 50 minutes
um so anyways I'm gearing up for this
um
this stand-up uh tour that I have coming
up and I'm gonna be playing
doing a nice stand up running my hour
hit Flappers possibly another place
going to be bouncing around La all this
week uh getting ready to go just going
back to being a [__] comedian again I
can't wait to do it I'm so ridiculously
excited to uh
go out to Southeast Asia and even though
this time you know I'm not spending a
lot of time in any of these places but
this is how I I handled Europe I just
kept going there just business business
and then once I started selling tickets
I was actually able to slow down
and uh taking some sites so I plan on
doing that throughout southeast Asia so
there's some quick things that I'm going
to do when I go to Hong Kong I don't
know how long I'm going to be there but
at some point I'm going to get some
[__] dumplings
touchdown Patriots
sorry
there we go now it's going to be 31 to
7. so it's looking pretty good here
um
Paul verzi would have called this game
at 14 nothing
so so
uh I got a smoker cigar with that guy
Jesus Christ it's been a while so when I
go to uh Hong Kong I'm going to uh I'm
definitely going to try to get dumpling
somewhere
when I go to India uh India I think is
going to be
I don't know I think that that's going
to be actually a bigger culture shock
than when I go to like Shanghai and and
um
in Hong Kong this might be ignorant of
me but I feel like I've gone to uh
Chinatown enough times
you know what I mean I've gone to San
Francisco and gone down there and you
walk there and there's just so many
people uh Asian people that you for the
most part feel like you are
somewhere in Asia but I've never been
towns don't really have like a little
India you know they have Little Italy
Italy little Armenia
Thai Town they'll have Chinatown and
that type of stuff but I've never gone
to a place where I was just surrounded
by nothing but Indian people so I think
it's going to be uh
an amazing experience and I had a buddy
of mine who actually uh one of my flight
instructors was just over in Hong Kong
and he said it's the coolest City he's
ever been to hands down
which is so [__] awesome to hear
um
and I also like China anyways just
because they were The Underdogs where as
far as little I know about Asia like
Japan was kind of like the white people
over there where they're like we are the
Supreme people and we're now going to
try to enslave everybody over there you
know what I mean uh they were sort of
the they had the European mentality
and uh
I don't know everybody else is sort of
the underdog so I know there's just
something about it something I read
about Bruce Lee one time I read this
thing that uh the Japanese back in the
day said that the Chinese were animals
so
Bruce Lee was fighting in this Chinese
style defeating these Shogun Warriors
and after he kicks their ass in the
movie he says by the way I'm not an
animal
and in China they like the movie theater
just stood up and gave a standing
ovation I was like that's the [__] I
hope that's true so anyways I'm looking
forward to going over there and uh it's
killing me
that I won't be anywhere near the Great
Wall of China
because uh that's definitely on my
bucket list but I figure if I keep going
over to Hong Kong
and I can build up a Following over
there eventually I'll make enough money
where I can then blow it on another I
figure I gotta jump on another plane
I don't even know where the Great Wall
is is it in Beijing
I know I can't jump in a [__] Prius
over there and drive to it
uh I would be terrified to do it because
I figure once I get out of Hong Kong the
road signs are no longer in English and
I would be [__]
that's so uh Singapore it fascinates me
uh I'm not gonna lie to you I am nervous
that I am going to say something on
stage that will get me caned
um I promise you if I get into that
situation I will try to remain calm
enough before the first strike to yell
out though Jesus yeah oh Jesus before
then and then any [__] sounds I make
after that I don't want to [__] hear
it unless you got caned
um
and then I have all of Australia and New
Zealand and uh I just think it's gonna
be uh
you know come on man this is like some
[__] that people bid on at the end of
the [__] price is right and I get to
do it while telling jokes man I'm pretty
much uh I'm pretty much stealing money
not to mention when I go over there my
biggest [__] problem is gonna be uh
cigars
because Cuban cigars are legal over
there and I I kind of made a New Year's
resolution that I was going to smoke
only one a week
because you figure that's still 52
[__] cigars A year that's a lot of
[__] cigars
unless you smoke cigars then it's a joke
so
um for the month of January
I unfortunately have already smoked five
I smoked one at the Rose Bowl then I
smoked two during the Patriots game last
week
I smoked two in New Orleans
and um
I was going to smoke one today I was
like I can't because I'm already for the
allotted time I'm already into February
so I have to somehow get through this
week in my first [__] uh
week of Australia without smoking but I
gotta tell you uh today
you know
uh today was tough I got a nice back
porch area
always really calling to me Jesus Christ
I really I I am addicted to those
[__] things I got to admit I'm
[__] addicted and I got to work on
that but anyways that is the podcast for
this week uh congratulations to uh the
Seattle Seahawks franchise
and all the fans that stayed
at all the ones that were back there in
the Kingdome uh my condolences to all
the [__] fans of the Green Bay
Packers
um can anybody anybody was in code
there's got to be somebody in coaching
you know I don't give a [__] what what
level you coach can you please explain
to me the prevent defense and just do
you have any numbers it has to work way
more than it doesn't work
um
I don't know I just think as a fan I
hate it because even if we win I still
have to go through [__]
the amount of stress that it puts me
through
just drives me up the [__] wall it's
just like you've been kicking their ass
just keep kicking their [__] ass can
anybody in coaching please for the love
of God help me oh and by the way I had
an epic battle with Giannis Pappas and
uh Paul verzi
got the Babe Ruth thing going again I
know it bugs some of you guys but I know
a lot of you guys enjoyed it and
actually trying to beat those guys I
mean it was a [__] 2-1-1 so I was
taking my hits like to think I was
dishing them out too
um oh by the way Paul verzy on the verzy
effect sat down with Giannis Pappas and
they allegedly destroyed me on the Babe
Ruth debate here's some interesting
stats outside of Babe Ruth to tell you
why I feel like it was an inferior
League
all right Ted Williams was the last guy
to ever hit 400. he did it in 1941.
nobody has done it since
so that 70 coming on 70 74 Seasons going
on 75 years
nobody has hit 400 yet prior to the 1942
baseball season
hitting 400 had been done 28 times
in a little over 60 years
okay
every guy who did it was white and did
it in an all-white League
and after 1941 it was never done again
prior to 1941 they averaged somebody
doing it almost every two years two to
two and a half years two to three years
somebody hit 400. Honus Wagner
Ty Cobb and some guy Ed McDermott or
some [__] you know what they have in
common all three of them not only did
they hit 400 they did it three [__]
times
and this is what funny
I brought that up to Giannis and I go
dude there was a guy
in the 1870s or 1880s hit 434 for the
season and he goes oh that's ridiculous
and it is ridiculous compared to 1925
hitting 434 in 1875 is ridiculous but 19
1925 as compared to 1965 to me is also
ridiculous what you have during the
all-white era
okay
what you have is you have not only with
Babe Ruth
you have straight across the board
unprecedented offensive numbers
pick off by the Patriots
whoa
um
do you know in the 1930s I did a quick
quick research I might be wrong for all
you baseball heads out there
every year in the 1930s except one year
to win the RBI Crown you had to hit at
least 170 RBIs
Honus Wagner hit a hundred and not home
swing sorry uh uh uh Hank Greenberg
Hank Greenberg had 191 [__] RBIs
okay and what you notice with all of
these crazy [__] stats guys having 30
win Seasons guys pitching double headers
guys winning 500 [__] games all of
that [__]
what you notice is there's this
ridiculous level of [__] stats
and then when the game becomes
integrated all of a sudden those those
numbers go down and they level the [__]
off
all right and I really feel stats from
the 50s 60s 70s touchdown Patriots
LeGarrette Blount we're going to the
Super Bowl into the 80s
um
into the 80s like those are leveled off
[__] numbers and some of the greatest
pitchers and some of the greatest
hitters of all time played from the 50s
into the [__] 80s and none of them
came anywhere close
to winning hitting
long balls any of that [__] [__]
other than uh Roger Maris who hit 61
home runs
okay I guess some I think Mantle hit
like 57 home runs or whatever but
I'm saying and then all of a sudden
you had a game
that was just steeped in its past
and all the great records and all the
[__] we're all all held by these [__]
guys whose baseball cards were inside of
cigar boxes
all right and then you notice all of a
sudden
those records start getting broken again
they liven up the ball they made the
stadium smaller they livened up the ball
they made the stadium smaller and guys
started doing steroids and still the the
most [__] RBIs anybody ever hit was
Manny Ramirez 165.
Sammy Sosa got 160. both of those guys
were on roids
and even they couldn't get 170. 180
forget about 191. nobody's hitting 400
I'm telling you and you're also talking
about like all the pitches back then the
curveball the slider split finger
fastball cut fastball all of those
pitches were being developed
so you had a guy like Babe Ruth who had
in any era monster Talent
showing up that yeah that guy's gonna do
some [__] damage and he's going to
put up unprecedented [__] numbers and
for these guys to sit there and suggest
that in
2014-15 if this guy [__] played that
not only would he get his 700 something
home runs he would also be a Cy Young
award-winning pitcher
it doesn't even [__] make sense
okay
that a guy that talented could [__]
exist and then never is there another
guy that talented again and despite
everything that you saw in a incredible
athlete like Bo Jackson do
nothing Bo Jackson did
as far as statistics go despite the fact
that he was that he was arguably
definitely gonna be a Hall of Famer in
uh baseball and arguably he had the the
talent to be a Hall of Famer in baseball
the fact that even what he did in his
short time paled in comparison to what
[__] Babe Ruth did Babe Ruth played in
an all-fucking white league and some of
you guys will argue well there was only
10 12 teams and it's like fine okay
let's take today's baseball and Whittle
it all the way down to 12 teams with
those 12 teams then go back to being
only white guys they wouldn't they would
still be the best of the best
okay which when it's all legal and fair
seems to be predominantly Latino in that
sport so those people would not be
allowed to play and right there it
becomes inferior so I feel like
I'm still giving Babe Ruth
600 plus home runs for his career
all right but he would have had to have
decided to either be a great pitcher or
a great hitter that's how it would have
[__] gone down
all right and
that's it I'm not going to debate this
any [__] more I really feel that Babe
Ruth played essentially
you had an any era Hall of Fame dominant
[__] player that played against
division one college Talent
and I think that is a fact and I don't
give a [__] what you say
I think because everybody loves baseball
they're just so steeped in that history
that is absolutely sacrilegious
to talk about these [__] guys and the
records that they had in their 500
[__] wins and all of this [__] I'm
telling you man come on at the beginning
I I maintain it watching Kobe score 80
something points
in the 2000s is is more I think that's
more difficult to [__] do than to
score 100 points like Will Chamberlain
in the 1960s that's just how I feel
you know you got a hundred [__] years
of
this is what it defense wins
championships so if you're going to be
successful they figure they they would
pitch around Babe Ruth they would figure
out how to they would figure out how to
neutralize
his talents
okay
dude Babe Ruth went up it we was hitting
against [__] an all-white League he
went up against a guy who sold shoes in
the [__] off season like these guys
didn't even make enough [__] money I
mean if your Babe Ruth you did but
this guy that the level of talent he was
playing against was so piss-poor this
guy could go out and booze and eat cakes
and hot dogs not even work out
you know look I'm not saying the guy was
wasn't one of the greatest of all time
but you know when John Goodman
gets selected to play you
in the [__] movie of your life I mean
give me a [__] break all right I'm
done that's it that's the podcast go
[__] yourself
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast to NFL
Edition NFL playoff edition and they say
this is the best week of them all
everybody this is divisional I actually
like wild card week better than this
week to be honest with you but hey
what's going to say why is this one
better they say this is the best one I
like wild card myself
you know but here we are and Bill had a
Bill had a good week Bill had I had a
hope I started good dude I had hey did
Paul had a rough one if it wasn't listen
if it wasn't for these guys if it wasn't
for these guys I would have been old for
all of it dude I [__] I had to charge
wait a minute real quick before we get
into this
I I still it's beyond me Bill and you
knew
the Los Angeles charges are up 27 to
nothing and the Jaguars threw four picks
in the first half four four
and they [__] lost the game they lost
the game 31-30 and all of my friends
like Bill and bartnick and everybody
just go yeah that's what the Charger's
doing I'm going this is the best team on
paper it was [__] horrible ah it was
uh four four
um well Bill you said bill you always
say Bill always says if you throw a pick
six it's tough then he throws two or
whatever no I used to say if you throw a
pick six you're not gonna win the game
now because they've so made it offense
friendly yeah all of these Sports you
know you dunk on nobody in the NBA and
you [__] scream like you're in 300
after you do it and everybody says It's
amazing
football now you have to throw two pick
sixes and then it's over that's what now
I think that that's the new rule dude
because I was talking on my podcast like
how many more of these [__] no-name
backups Paul
are just gonna step in yeah and then do
something that Joe Montana couldn't do
or Roger Staubach like that kid party on
San Francisco he won his first five
games nobody's ever done that and it's
just like is that cause he's so good am
I really supposed to think that or have
you made if you've tipped the scales
I think they've made being quarterback
as close to t-ball as you possibly can
because offense gets the Casual viewer
um I I don't know what but I've never
seen so many people from who gives a
[__] Community College step in for a guy
that played at USC and just you know
throw for 300 yards win four or five
[__] games in a row remember who was
this guy yeah I don't buy it yeah yeah
they like play to protect them too
um I'm sorry what's his face for the
[__] dolphins who the hell is that
guy oh sometimes those blow for blow
with Josh Allen who came from the
[__]
Mountain West League
yeah
um
dude I talked to somebody who was a
charger fan and they go Paul
I listened to your pick and I go dude it
was 27 nothing I called my boy and he
goes dude my buddy Birds he knows I'm
telling you dude it's 27 nothing he was
so right and I go dude I'm so sorry I
said I've never seen it he goes and I
never said anything like that I've never
seen anything like you have four not
four you have four
I've built I don't think anybody's
throwing forward what the Atlanta
Falcons did in a [__] Super Bowl
I know that was that was unbelievable
that was unbelievable the four picks was
taking that [__] sack
knowing what was on the line it was
insane I know 12-yard loss
um
so Bill Bill you had a well you had hey
you had a better who didn't have a
better week than me okay thank you thank
you Giants uh some point I had to win
something we're going into Jacksonville
I just yeah as I was saying San Diego in
the playoffs this is what they do San
Diego plays Jacksonville the week before
the end of December they win that game
35-3 handily
going away they all go to Orlando they
go to Disney World they have a great
[__] time it becomes January here's
here's how bad that game was Stacy went
to bed when it was 27 nothing going into
halftime Lucas went to bed they woke up
and my wife who could give a [__] about
the Jaguars or the charges looked at her
phone and she just goes the Jaguars won
um I think that the Chargers logo should
not be that lightning bolt it should be
LaDainian Tomlinson on a [__]
exercise bike the guy runs over the
whole [__] League the whole year you
can't stop him and then playoffs come
around he gets hurt he's got to be on
he's on an exercise bike he looks like
he's in a Richard Simmons video
well the San Diego Chargers have the New
England Patriots beat they stop us on
fourth down they take an unnecessary
roughness call and blow the game this is
what they do
this is what they do
dude if my Giants were up 27 nothing and
blew it you would see me walk off like
what when they held what's his name
Kelly Winslow you and bartnick would be
on one side I'd have puke coming off my
beard
now imagine this Paul because as bad as
what they do yeah they still have that
great San Diego weather because they're
always going to be the San Diego
Chargers to me all right
not the football version of the LA
Clippers sharing somebody else's Stadium
Clippers by the way getting their own
stadium for whatever [__] reason
because it's not it's not 100 degrees
out enough
per year uh days per year
um at least they have the nice weather
paw
what if you were the San Diego Chargers
and it was so cold out you had to build
tunnels underneath your street during
the winter like you were in the Arctic
I'm talking about the Minnesota Vikings
ball who also
play great I can't even say all year
they play great up until about November
they get in the playoffs it's a home
game everybody has a Juicy Lucy they go
down there they dress like rapist
rapists and pillaging Vikings and what
happens Paul
the karma of all that raping and
pillaging comes back and they lose every
year
remember that guy they went 15-1 just
absolutely stacked and lost through the
Atlanta Falcons the Falcons who invent
ways to lose in the playoffs they lost
to them what what is it about a
franchise that stays that way that stays
that franchises are historically the
same for decades it's really [__]
weird man the players change but the
results do not dude Chicago Bears same
team forever even my Giants the Giants
are the weirdest team
they beat a team that everybody thinks
they're going to lose to then they lose
to a shitty to like ever is everybody is
the same the saying they need to get rid
of Eli they got to get rid of the coach
then they get a wild card and then they
[__] won't go the whole thing and
they beat an 18-0 New England Patriots
team yeah that's what they do
that's what they do so why would so why
would you fix that there's no reason to
fix whatever the Giants are doing
because it's working
the Vikings I don't know I mean I'll
give it to them in the 70s they weren't
on steroids what about the lights in the
steroid game what about the Lions the
Jets same [__] the lions are
family-owned from what I've heard and
the initial guy that bought the team
knew football and that's when they had
Bobby Lane and they won all their titles
their last titles and then throughout
the years it's just been passed down to
the fredos and the bottom line is
you know even if you're not into
football it's a billion dollar [__]
Corporation you're not going to get into
that business when you're secretly want
to be a barista that's yeah Paul they
have a [__] Barista as an owner but
what is family owned mean the Giants are
family owned the Robert Kraft owns the
the what does family family run
family run okay like you have to go to
the family hey you got to go to the
family you got to talk to them
like I I talked to a guy that played on
the team he goes don't ever [__] [__]
on Wayne fonsick he had all these moves
he wanted to make but he had to [__]
go upstairs
and talk to these video playing game
whatever they were they weren't football
people Wayne fonts I loved that guy
um all right guys what's his uncle and
he really did he he had that old Italian
he had that old Italian
um bocce ball
before we get into the picks guys we got
a shout out the bed MGM sponsor best
lines out there guys and uh you you too
can play with us uh all you got to do is
you got to download the BET MGM app use
bonus code Burr that's Burr very simple
and guess what everybody guess what you
put as little as 10 bucks in they're
gonna match it up to a thousand you
gotta stack for free even if you lose
all you got to do is you got to go to
the bed MGM app you got to download it
you gotta use bonus code b-u-r-r Burr
and there you go and then you're a part
of our show and you're betting with us
and uh you're losing money like I did
last week I'm kidding we're gonna get it
back this week all right here we go
um all right so with the first game
Andrew though what's the first game on
the docket here
first game Saturday is the Jacksonville
Jaguars at the Kansas City Chiefs
Jacksonville Jaguars at the Kansas City
Chiefs minus nine yeah I got Kansas City
all day Jacksonville the uh the slipper
turns into a [__] alligator slider
and they go right back to Jacksonville
I'm with you on that I don't see them I
don't see them Mahomes rested I don't
see that happening so the Holmes is
going to do the purse throw
yeah yeah
it drives me up the [__] wall so
stupid it goes [__] half a yard and
the announcers are gonna be like oh my
God
it's like I used to do that deliver in
newspapers yeah that's backyard football
with your friends and they're going nuts
it's like yeah he stopped before the
line of scrimmage and he did that it's
not that nuts right and then the blind
man can't [__] tackle him or touch
them because it's roughing so that they
gotta like pull up
this person
um no I don't either his knees
[__] Magic Johnson thrown it through
trees behind his [__] goddamn head oh
dude you got to see this video there's
an old clip of Dan Marino practicing
with his team like and he's almost at
the he's at the 40 dude and his teammate
is in the end zone and he just takes the
ball and he [__] does around the back
dude and it is a like a 35 yard dude
right it was it was not stood
um all right what's the second game
Andrew
are the over under on that's 53 by the
way if uh
I like the Yonder yeah me too
all right Chiefs in the under uh next
games Paul's New York Giants versus the
Philadelphia Eagles and that's minus
seven and a half it was eight yesterday
uh now it's minus seven I love the
Giants
I I think the Giants are clicking I like
them with the points I like them with
the points I love the half a point take
the Giants for sure
dude Daniel the Eagles are going to beat
you three times in a [__] row I I
really don't and I think that we're
clicking really good I think if we could
keep it within a possession we'll pull
it off in the end but dude how about
Daniel Jones in in Minnesota kid looked
you didn't see the game dude it was
really awesome man
put up a stat line that hasn't been done
80 yards rush in 300 yards passing two
touchdowns zero interceptions oh yeah in
2023 pop yeah and what about Purdy and
[__] Joe blowing and all of these
[__] guys you you guys really have a
quarterback from Duke
Joe Montana numbers Paul I'm done with
this it's an entertainment League I mean
an entertainment League you can do all
you want Paul every [__] out
there now can throw for 300 yards and
run for 80 yards it's insane it's
ridiculous
I mean running for 80s a lot for a
quarterback man got to give a little
credit is it running for 80. oh they got
five white outs they just send them down
you're telling me a white guy from duke
can run for 80 yards in an NFL game as a
quarterback okay
okay all right yeah yeah all right I
love I love him being white It's the
funniest thing white guy from duke makes
it in the NFL [__] like when's the
[__] playoff game and runs for 80
yards fall if I told you
20 years ago that that was going to
happen before [__] Jim ursay and all
those [__] yeah it's just [__] rules
yeah you would say you're out of your
[__] mind it sounds like a true false
question true or false a white guy from
duke ran for 500 yards in an NFL season
ah sounds like a movie Hollywood would
buy yeah
um I like the giant we definitely agree
on the Giants
um now we get into the hard games
what's the next one
Cincinnati Bengals oh are in Buffalo and
uh Buffalo oh Buffalo's giving five and
a half I love Cincinnati all day long
I'm torn on this one I had Cincy all
week I had Cincy all week but I don't
know oh you know what just to make it
fun and interesting I had Cincy all
weekend I'm gonna change it I'm gonna
say Josh Allen and Stefan Diggs finish
what they [__] started I thought they
were emotionally spent I don't like how
they played against the Dolphins but I
actually think that that's going to work
to their advantage I'm gonna take them
to beat Joe burrow and the Bengals and I
think they're gonna [__] do it by by
six points oh I don't know about that
one bill that one that one felt
different when I said it yeah no uh
until the Bills win a [__] Super Bowl
they are the Chargers they are the
Vikings they are the Falcons it's what
they do they almost [__] blew it last
week against some guy named [__]
Skyler
let me ask you this question what
happens to Buffalo
what happens to Buffalo and that
organization if they go to the Super
Bowl like against the Niners and lose
dude dude I'm gonna tell you right now
if there's eight minutes left in that
game and they're gonna lose that game
I'm shutting it off how to refill Bill
the pain that you're facing Buffalo
they're the pain on your face when I
even was asking the question because I
knew where it was going oh
you know what's going to happen is a
third of the population of Buffalo is
gonna walk into Lake Erie and just say
I've had it
yeah
there's actually I would say probably
eight percent of their fan base is
rooting against Buffalo this week just
to get it over with
and just be like you know what if we
lose it to divisional level NFL films
won't make another [__] chapter of us
being these Sad Sack losers but if we go
to another [__] Super Bowl and I it
you know I mean you got to think as a
Bills fan that you like
if we're not going to win the Super Bowl
just lose this [__] week because I
don't need to to watch it
I don't need to blow another three grand
going to [__] New Orleans or wherever
the hell they're gonna have it this year
oh my god dude
it'd be worse if you lost if they lost
this year and then next year they went
back and instead of being excited for
their team to be back in the Super Bowl
next year they have to go oh [__] Are we
going to lose two in a row what if it
what about this what if it's Giants
bills like it was 1990 and this time the
bills go wide left
[Laughter]
and they lose to a white guy quarterback
from duke and he runs for 90 yards
uh so Bill you got the Bengals I'm gonna
take the bills and uh yeah I mean that's
gonna do that's gonna be a good one
um under 49 on that over under 49
I think I like the you know what the
[__] worst is right now is their fan
base is buying into the fact that that
tragic thing happened to their
cornerback I know that their America's
team and people are rooting for them
it's just like it's literally like
watching Charlie Brown try to kick a
football it's like can you guys please
guard your emotions
how do you not until they [__] win
the goddamn thing can you please as a
Buffalo Bills fan guard your motion they
want my Super Bowl pick I am rooting for
them
Paul we got money on this actually hold
on I Gotta Give I gotta give a shout out
to Bill on that because I had the
Chargers who had all the [__] talent
that they should have did they
you can't well it's on you it's on you
you've been what you're a big boy Paul
come on now you know what you said
you've been watching footballs from
[__] oh my God damn you know what
they do Paul you know what they do I
have been watching them I've been
watching football seriously since I'm 11
12 years old and I haven't seen Talent
like that on a team a quarterback like
that you can't give up 27 points you
have you have and you've seen them lose
you told me you the Patriots that's the
greatest offense I've ever seen you
watch your own team beat him
it was a bit still was incredible you
saw the 15-1
[__] Minnesota Vikings lose to the
goddamn dirty birds and the next week
that quarterback gets kicked out of the
game because he's out there banging
horse he hasn't missed a kick all year
remember that Scott you saw
Bill Belichick on the Giants shut down
John Elway and Jim Kelly in the running
gun you saw Bill Belichick shut down the
greatest show on Turf that Ricky Pro was
going [__] in the dynasty Begins the
dynasty Begins the Dynasty is over
and your stadium is now a Whole Foods in
St Louis they don't have a [__] team
don't you [__] sit there and tell me
you haven't seen this before Paul Percy
and this I will drive out to your house
and I will clear the olive oil off your
shelf you have to say something like
that again
dude I'm all my teams are out of it I
said at first I said Chargers Niners and
then I said no scratch the Niners
Packers so my my Super Bowl teams are
out but they can't lay off a team with
yellow in the uniform
it looks like gold to him he starts
thinking about the chain around his neck
and he will ride or die your loyalty is
what you should have beaten the book by
20 games
Bill who did you have in the NFC dude I
think did you have the Niners
dude did you have the bills and the
Niners I think you did
I don't know who I am I might have said
nice I don't think I did who else would
I have a pie well you you definitely
said Buffalo and I think for the NFC
dude you were you were teetering with
Niners or somebody else so you you may
have both of you we got to go to week
one I definitely didn't say Eagles no
you did not say Eagles you did not say
Giants you did not say Cowboys dude I
say Tampa
you either said you either said Tampa or
Niners versus the bills Tampa is my
Green Bay but you know it's Tom Brady
what am I supposed to do here
all right so we got we got
um
we both have no we he's got the the
Bengals I got the the bills and then now
we go into the final game which is the
NFC uh big one it's the Cowboys who
looked really good in San Francisco
what's that line
it's uh Cowboys are getting four
Cowboys are getting four I'm taking I
can't believe I'm saying it I'm doing it
I'm taken
I can't believe it Jack Prescott and the
Cowboys to go in there and get to Brock
Purdy okay are you out of your mind Paul
from Purdy won the first five no one's
ever done that
gonna hit the Kid hard he's gonna make a
mistake and get flustered I'm taking
this the two scariest words in January
in the NFL are Brock and Purdy
you thought Skyla what's his face was
scary
you thought Daniel Jones the white guy
from duke the White Hope hey hey
Adventure some yards you haven't seen
Brock Purdy against
the Dallas Cowboys demos where did Purdy
go to college we got we got Daniel Jones
at Duke I want to know where Brock I'm
gonna bet you 50 bucks I could get
accepted at that school
hold on I'm gonna guess Wyoming
Colorado State
oh you guys are both pretty close Iowa
State University all right we're right
there you go neighbors Rock Purdy from
Iowa State hey I'll tell you right now
that is a football Factory out there in
Iowa State
birdies have to come into the league
before these Scouts start hanging around
Iowa State
so Bill who you got four points the
49ers all [__] day long because I'll
tell you right now when the owner of
your team has more Botox than Rings
right
that's actually not true he's got three
of them that guy that that that
organization's problem is him
all right I don't know what he is he
looks like he goes to Epstein Islands I
don't like it he just does he has that
creepy
oh
creepy like [__] laminated I'd own a
yacht and nobody was even born in the
same Century that's on it face so I
gotta go with the San Francisco 49ers
okay shout out to happy milk I'm going
laying
Paul wait wait 49ers laying four laying
um
that's probably a Thumpback I'm just I'm
kind of going this week with who I think
is gonna win
because they're probably uh I don't know
if that defense dude I think they're
gonna I don't think Dak Prescott has the
greatest team around him I don't think
he's the problem I think people who just
watch the ball think he's the problem I
don't think he's the problem
the problem
is all the way up that super fast
elevator fall
I think the Man parties I think Brock
Purdy's little special run here is is
going to come too it's going to show its
rear its ugly head in a big moment and I
think the Cowboys get to him and make
him make a mistake and I think the
Cowboys go in there and win that game
and go to an NFC Championship hey Paul I
got a line for you there's nothing ugly
about Purdy
how about this one in the morning in the
paper not so Purdy that's still pretty
oh yeah
all right so now we'll just do a parlay
we do a parlay so real quick just just
so we have this bill and I have the
chiefs together we both have the chiefs
minus nine we both have the Giants plus
seven and a half
take that to the [__] bank yeah
that's my [__] layup of the week he
has the Bengals I have the bills five
and a half oh you can take that to an
offshore account
he has the Niners I have the Cowboys
right to Epstein Islands
over under 46 on that hey you heard the
new Bond that they're making
yeah
wait I knew the new kid that they picked
they picked the kid from uh they picked
the kid from that bullet train movie
yeah they remember the Man with the
Golden Gun yeah they're rebooting it
to the man with the laminated face Jerry
Jones
the man with the shiny face
uh I thought you were serious because
they just picked a new Bond
it's about a guy with a yacht in his own
Island
and he's got this ray gun he's gonna uh
I can't say all this stuff about him he
doesn't do [__] like that I'm sorry he
met you may meet him one day and he may
say hey bail man just want to say you're
welcome at this park anytime I don't
yeah I don't I don't do
[__] human beings over a certain age
that are that thin with a face that's
shiny I don't want to be anywhere in
their Circle
yeah no
um it reminds me of a certain I can't
say it I can't I saw a [__]
I saw this [__] creepy guy one time
at a game he was hanging out with all of
these you could see it was all younger
people and there's mainly younger chicks
I had good seats Paul I was down near
the corporate [__] right
so everybody went down to go get you
know their free food underneath and and
he's sitting there and one of the hot
chicks came back early and she and she
had the uh please don't sexually assault
me empty seat between the two of them
and he looked over there and he he
tapped the seat that was next to him
we had to get up and sit next to the guy
you're [__] awful uh
and I felt bad for it but then on
another level I was like looking at her
like
the [__] are you doing yeah
yeah
it's like you literally just felt your
body go no I wanna not only do I not
want to sit in that seat I want it's one
of the worst things they don't teach
young people to listen to that little
thing in their stomach that goes this
guy's a creep yeah
foreign
all I thought about when you said that
was if my daughter was ever around
people with money just because of that I
did a bad job as a father which would
never I wish I yelled hey hair plugs she
doesn't want to sit next
don't do it honey you know you don't
want to
your pubes have more snow in it than the
North Pole you're wrong wrap it up
you're old viagra's cheating
Paul
what the amount of guys still out there
banging chicks because of [__] Viagra
I mean that's not Peds the amount of
people that are on Viagra
like literally took it and that dick is
standing up as they're watching ESPN go
look at this guy taking steroids I knew
he was a cheater here's here's the deal
though if your dick takes a dive in its
40s or 50s dude if your dick goes down
early you got to do something you get
into coaching
you get a desk job at ESPN on the
Playboy Channel you start telling people
talking about Your Glory Days
dude what is that what makes a dick
[__] throw in the towel at 50. what
like what what is it is it is it it's
it's like five Decades of Pop-Tarts and
ho-hos
y juice really I'm not a doctor
I don't know what it is
yeah but you go from like this [__]
horny young man who's like yeah it's
just like
maybe she sucks the life buddy
you know what it is Paul it's all of
those years of right as your ass is
about to hit the seat she goes oh honey
did you just do me a quick favor and
after a while your tank starts to
collapse and you know that today detains
connected to the ball bag the bowl base
next to the shaft joint I got one for
you I got one for you ready ready it's
third and eight it's third and eight
fourth quarter two minutes left one
possession game NFC Championship
okay it's all about Bernard party all
day right under Center no no no it's
third and eight if they get this it's a
whole they're going to the Super Bowl
your wife calls you in the shower
but you gotta go at that moment do you
leave the play
no
you watch the game and rub one out you
send her flowers the next day
that's one of the easiest questions ever
ah dude I was hanging from a gutter
about to fall for my death with my head
on fire and the Real Housewives finale
was on I'm gonna die
laughs
oh dude it is what it is uh and she'll
have the nerve to cry at my funeral
oh my God Bill dude you're cute my
stomach is hurting dude [__] I'm getting
all kinds of looks
are you oh yeah my wife just came into
the room uh
hi Nia hi I love how you just said hi
Nia hang on I know I'm like a scared I'm
like I'm from New York I'm not here I'm
not here no my wife's cool that's so
funny dude
uh get that cool come on
Karen
I gotta come home
tennis come on you got to do it one time
there
I'm sorry
that's our favorite line in a movie I'm
sorry
what about uh you gotta really go ah
she's she's starting to cry yeah she
goes
starts to cry remember
he goes he wanted to go to jail he
wanted to get away that's why these guys
that was my favorite thing of how dumb
like making how dumb the wives would be
he wanted to go to these guys didn't get
caught they want to go to jail like do
you know what we're doing that's not
gonna happen to us
the Bengals are gonna cover
they wanted to lose the tuition for
their son you know how you blow a
27-nothing lead with four interceptions
you want to lose
Asante Samuel got three interceptions in
the first quarter because he wanted to
Karen
okay
all right
dude all right here we go so the last
thing we're gonna do a little parlay
Giant Eagles bill Giants Eagles
um and NFC East rivalry match-up
Daniel Jones passing we have choices
Daniel Jones rushing 50 yards under over
or passing 240.
uh anytime touchdown one or two
Jalen hurts the same numbers passing
rushing anytime touchdown same thing
saquon Barkley 80 rushing yards 25
receiving yards any any time touchdown
um Isaiah Hodgkins AJ Brown Devonta you
know we could just go on so I like a
guy's name Isaiah and Devonte that
sounds fast that sounds like a lot of
yards
Isaiah Hodgkins is the Giants faster
than [__] Daniel Jones to get more
than 80 yards I can tell you that
um is that his GPA or am I really
supposed to sit here and think that this
guy's gonna
he's [__] fast dude don't you know
dude he [__] fell down
because it's so because he's so fast
[Laughter]
yeah this guy was running down the field
he he looked like me chasing after a
toddler and then he just fell down on
his face
[Music]
oh you guys such a good day it happens
there you go by the way shout out to the
Dallas Cowboys kicker
who had to Bear the brunt of all the
[__] people out there that are so
miserable with their life I could not
believe how much people were enjoying
watching him having the worst day of his
[__] life in front of everybody you
[__] hang in there
yeah
yeah talk about it that's right there
dude if I taught like the [__] class
in college I would I would show what
that guy went through and then people's
reaction to it on [__] Twitter
and I would be like this is why
you only have two or three friends in
life
this is why you don't listen to most
people because they're [__] miserable
I actually was hurting for him when on
the third Miss in a row he the stare he
gave at it after it missed he he looked
and then he it went from confusion to
anger to just his his career it was
really [__] up man yeah it was brutal
who the [__] wants to see somebody lose
their job dude I walk out of a room when
a comic is bombing when Comics like it
and laugh I actually don't when I see a
comic up there really struggling dude
I'll I'll I see if they're gonna get out
of it with the next joke and I leave
but if they don't know how to control it
but if it's if it's a guy that's funny
and he's up there laughing like trying
new [__] and bombing I want that's
different because you're laughing with
them but like to sit there and watch
somebody like
oh
just have one of those yeah
and you see them sweating and they're
like anyway and it I don't I can't guys
are like liking it I'm like ah dude no
man this guy's like you know I'm out I'm
out dude
I'm not big on that watching a car crash
[__] although in traffic last night I
went around one which made me feel bad
uh you know commend you that you didn't
go through one
all right so what do you think you want
to do say Quan We Could Andrew could we
pick and choose I hated every [__]
thing I heard about what to bet on there
I don't believe saquon Barkley has is
gonna [__] if he didn't do it last
week he's not going to do it against the
Eagles
um
what if he just breaks one dude
uh Paul likes that what if he just
breaks one for [__] 55 yards in the
first quarter he's got a
I think saquan goes over 80 yards maybe
82. that's a great Paul you know what
this is your world this is the Giants
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with you I saw
what you did on Rich Eisen the Rich
Eisen show I did
oh my god dude I want that as a meme
I did rich rich I go rich I go we might
go to the NFC Championship Game Eisen
goes this is in August before week one
he goes he goes Paul he goes NFC
Championship game like all right dude
what do you think I think they're going
to win 9-10 games and then I broke down
the games I was [__] almost nailed
everyone you be on broke down the games
you knew what kind of losses they were
going to be oh Rich Eisen goes oh he
said disappointing all right I like the
adjectives because I like the adjective
I'm one game away from predicting the
Giants in the NFC Championship on Rich
Eisen in August let's go Giants and then
we'll go Giants with the points seven
and a half or eight doesn't matter same
difference right pretty much oh you got
to have your people if they if they win
this week you gotta have your people
reach out to Rich eyes I I was thinking
that I said I gotta have uh I gotta have
my publicist reach out and get hit rich
don't forget he he's got to owe you a
Bud Light and a [__] hot dog or
something some sort of Stadium tip of
the cap if giant twin were taking that
clip from Bill and we're sending it
right to Rich's [__] inbox
uh
I want to be in the food you got to have
me doing the setup Paul you said that
[__] was gonna happen on Rich Eisen then
he cuts you going
I did
by the way shout out to how great of a
dude is Rich Eisen dead serious is that
guy one of the best on and off stage
just total solid guy amazing father
husband person and he's totally into
sports and he's a Michigan guy there's
nothing not to love about that guy even
if you go to Ohio State you begrudgingly
have to admit that he's a better human
being than anybody on that campus
he goes I told them the story about how
when I put my arm around Strahan at the
stand when I performed in front of him
and I looked at him and I go 07 changed
my life and I go I'm a grown man with
children and I actually said that too
and they all start laughing so at the
end of the segment with Eisen Eisen goes
come on yeah let's take a picture and we
took a picture and as we took a picture
he goes your appearance changed my life
it called it back it was so [__] it
was so [__] great all right so here's
to do stand up I think he was just stand
up first he started to stand up at
College he said I think he did it for
like three to five years or something
um all right so we're gonna take the
Giants with the points seven and a half
we're gonna take saquan to break one get
80. get 80 in a divisional game some
reason I'm seeing that I don't see him
getting to the end so I see him running
diagonally looking over his shoulder and
some [__] corner from the other side
running him down
I see saquon 101 101 yards and a
touchdown oh I love it and what's one
more bill under no I don't want to [__]
with the under over dude that's a coin
toss
what's the under over you want to do
Daniel Jones anytime touchdown
does that mean wait I can't touch the
Great White Hope does that mean throw
that means throw two though right Andrew
uh no
we didn't take last time anytime is okay
so can we do we can do Daniel Jones to
throw one sequan to rush over 80 and the
Giants with the points I mean what's the
biggest crowd this kid played in front
of in college
4 000 people no he put dude I saw him
get rocked at West Point and I remember
going oh my god dude a blind side he was
like this this dude from West Point
[__] exploded him and I go oh my God
that guy's so slow
now I'm like he's a deer he's a deer
this was a fun one this was one of the
most fun this was fun dude bill got me
crying on this one all right everybody
well there you go you got your
divisional games you got your divisional
games I can't believe I picked the
Cowboys and the Giants but hey
somebody's got to go down but can I just
say this and this is going to upset the
Kansas City fan base and I'm sorry and I
don't mean to do that because I know
Kansas City I think you want to do it
and I think you should
here's the thing I love being in Kansas
City I love the people there Patrick oh
this is gonna be bad it's gonna be bad
if you had to like [__] give the city
props before you talk about that team
this is gonna be bad
I'm gonna step out of frame for this
there's something there's something
about Patrick Mahomes and his camp that
really bugs me and I don't know what it
is there's something there's like an
arrogance I don't know if it's like his
wife and them yelling at fans ever since
I saw that I don't know if it's when he
does a like a flick listen I've seen the
guy make incredible passes they kind of
if I I want to see a little humbling of
of Mahomes is that bad to say
I would say it is because he hasn't won
the last few years he's one of the best
guys in the league
he lost Tyreek Hill they're having a
[__] unbelievable Year my only thing
is if you could just get rid of that
purse throw
if I just don't have to look at him do
the little [__] Paperboy shovel pass
and listen to some [__] enough
oh my God how did they come up with that
and I'm sitting there going like it's a
forward lateral that was what [__]
they've literally made forward laterals
legal
yeah you can [__] have your hand
under the ball in basketball
I mean you can do anything you want now
uh just score some [__] points so we
can get some more mouth breathing morons
to watch this [__] I actually like
Patrick Mahomes I don't like the way he
runs in that [__] Throne of the purse
drives me up the goddamn wall it's not
even his fault it's that the announcers
act like he [__] threw at 80 yards
oh
there goes my [__] ticket sales and
listen I I just don't I I just don't
really there's something about them I
don't really like I do like Travis
Kelsey maybe it's Kelsey every time he
gets three and a half yards he Stomps
around like he just won the MVP of the
Super Bowl
and I love Andy Reed
I love everything about them except
there's something I think it was I know
and he reads the only guy I won't go
with
Annie Reed anyway I want to roll that
guy right into the [__] all the way
to St Louis into the Mississippi because
it's funny oh why would you not like
that guy oh okay I'm saying yeah he
literally looks like he works for the
town
he does he's standing there next to an
orange cone as you drive by going
[__] do something
yeah he looks like he cuts down
Christmas trees for people in the
community like he's just and hey hey
yeah with this big puffy coat with
shorts on and his sausage fingers
Diversey
it was when Josh I mean it was when
Patrick Mahomes his whole like Camp was
going like this to fans that's what did
it for me you know what Andy Reid I
gotta say something he actually looks
like the BT cake serial killer
yeah but if he like [__] let go of
himself
uh no they look the same
oh BTK was big
it was just your typical bald fat-faced
Mustachio Midwestern guy out there
burning torturing and killing people
Paul there's not a lot to do out there
once you get past the corn fields then
you know you got to find your own fun
yeah yeah but I love it nobody knows how
to find the fun
like they do in Wisconsin
is it's it's the it's it's a breeding
ground for serial killers
[Laughter]
hey but they're nice people though other
than that the ones that aren't serial
kills are nice people
because you know what all of those
serial killers that they have
in Wisconsin they're all like Dexter
they only kill the bad people Paul
that's why when you go to Wisconsin
you're like wow people are so nice up
here no Domino's made all the bad ones
no they dominate any bad people
I mean you don't think so
no unless you're spotting I can't
believe how [__] serious you are this
is the dumbest thing I've ever said
yeah come on man I think some of those
guys were good shits
oh you said that's so seriously I was
like what do you mean uh
all right
uh hey Paul
I did
[Music]
all right I gotta get out of here
I got [__] to do all right enjoy your
football weekends guys now I know you
get all excited about the playoffs but
also remember to savor this football's
almost over I hate to be that guy saying
that what I [__] hate about this
weekend is how many teams are left
eight it'll be four next week thank you
it won't be five it'll be five well I'll
tell you man nobody does the math like
you
I know
after that'll be two then it'll be one
apparently I will make playoff match
simple for you yeah
every weekend and you will come up with
the right answer make sure you wipe
double checks you work
two right I did
after the Super Bowl no more games next
week yeah
hey Bill I want to put a grand on the
Pro Bowl this year just because it's
[__] this great dumb way to start the
year I'm going to it I'm going to go to
it because where is it it's in Vegas why
don't you come out
and they're playing flag football
they're not even they're not even in
pads all right I gotta come up with a
good lie to tell my wife how I can go to
Vegas Nia what's a good lie to tell you
to go to bed I'm gonna go to Vegas and
buy you something she goes I'm gonna go
to Vegas and buy you tell you something
that's a good one
everybody wins
no no she's saying I'm lying that I'm
not gonna buy her [__] she was trashing
me yeah but if you would if you did go
and bought or something what if I did go
and I bought you something what would
you like over there now yeah some sort
of uh
some sort of something some sort of
something some sort of something that
yeah over at the uh the cosmo stores
all right all right yeah
white leather bag yeah
Prada some [__] Italians really think
that solves all problems don't they dude
you give white letters hey we got a war
here with this other family saying I
just send him something white leather
tell me sorry sent over a little fresh
plate of pasta
three meats make sure you get the
[__] deal in there I don't care
yo they send Hitler like some white
leather thing he's like oh
that's why we got in with Mussolini
he bribed him some meatballs and some
[__] white leather oh dude you want
to talk about picking the wrong team
you know didn't do well on BET MGM
[__] Mussolini
well why wouldn't you they had Porsches
and Mercedes
[Laughter]
you have no idea what the [__] he was
doing
oh [__] dude all right go Giants have a
great week
I'll see you guys I love you guys
bye I did it I did all right I'll see
you and remember guys Tibet you got to
be 21 years of age or older to wager in
Arizona Colorado DC Iowa Indiana Kansas
Michigan Mississippi New Jersey New York
Nevada Pennsylvania Tennessee
uh Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming
only new customer offer paid in free
bets visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4704 Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]